doesn't do it and send me the link I hit
the button oh I hit the box afraid wait
ready ready oh god pretty oh man oh oh
sorry I had to like unleash my load what
do you get it well you gonna be like
that
I know gonna be like that having a
refreshing glass of DP and having
refreshing glass of whoop-ass whoa love
me some Tekken pad so what this is it
looks like decking yeah I know it's a
little faster I'm not a good size the
chat box damn people [ __ ] already here
what the [ __ ] guys yeah okay let's see
if Godzilla Mendoza's streaming I think
that guy's streaming do I think he's
dreaming yeah I think we'll find out
really can't tell hmm is that good I
made it I made the chat box like stretch
the whole lanes that is very nice it's
very nice
hi guys some people said hi to me people
want to know what's going on with the
Juche here I'm checking their screen
here pull the whole thing to the right a
little bit cuz it's extending beyond
what is oh it's better now actually I
like you're fine I lied to you
alright alright I'll just I'll leave it
as is so I'm squawk how's our sound hi
Becky oh if Becky's in here is Becky
listed as a as a mod as you know Tex and
Becks
and it's recognizer okay let's see
and moderator I smell like fish what the
[ __ ] dude they just came here to dunk on
you just took a shower what the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ] a lot of people tell me they
look they that they think I like don't
shower I'm like is it just because I
have long hair is that real fuzzy hair
bud is that what it is that it I shower
like once a day to the detriment of my
skin like to the point that it's super
dry what the [ __ ] well I guess that
makes sense
conditioner yeah is like why do you look
like a hobo I'm like I just I have hair
everyone's mean from your face trim your
hair Mortal Kombat chess yeah look isn't
that awesome [ __ ] ridiculous dude put
a lot of dumb [ __ ] in this yeah I like
it
I really like it all right that red
controller over there is yours oh wait I
have a round yeah I get to actually play
games this time yeah the d-pad on that
controller isn't very good it's quite
jank
I would agree do you want to send me a
link oh [ __ ] all right oh I got you I
got you what is it that's my job Audrey
Presley two dollars can you make more
videos relating to real comics as
opposed to fake comics as opposed to
Mortal Kombat comics which are art the
worstest oh man you know what I can't
wait to get to this part in the
retrospective where I talk about Mortal
Kombat two's tie-in comic cuz sub-zero
shows up and he's wearing sunglasses in
a suit and tie in his first appearance
and then he's like oh hello I am I am
sub-zero and they're like you don't look
like a ninja and he's like although I
don't dress like that all the time he's
looks like a normal dude and then it
cuts to a couple scenes later and he's
it like putting on the ninja outfit and
they're like oh okay now you look good
so in uh in answering that guy's
question no clearly well yeah hold on I
should do this I think I'm seeing more
night I got you oh my god
Pizza Man $4.99 he says hey Xavier have
you tried the ps2 spider-man to bonus
and game challenge where you fight four
bosses Doc Ock Rhino shocker and clips
at once have you I have not that sounds
[ __ ] baller
you'd hope I should try that didn't try
a similar stream all right joke asada $2
shave your red hair tomato head fix fix
what you broke Joe
do people are so [ __ ] mean did they
show up here just to pick on us yet day
gig that's what we're here for
why does the stream like why does it why
does the [ __ ] it's not the link is
just Godzilla Mendoza live which is just
gonna take people in my channel you're
super [ __ ] slow it's hard here wait
maybe I can just get the link for mmm I
can't share this can't I I totally can
there's gotta be anything you had a
Twitter account or someone tweet the
link and then I'll retweet it [ __ ]
genius look at this cool character his
name is Darius look I got the link easy
clap right I think he's some of his
moves are the same as Cyrax in the last
game for some reason Mortal Kombat likes
to perpetuate the that stereotype that
black people love yellow a stereotype is
that have you not okay my baby you're
just [ __ ] crazy maybe you're a racist
Xavier my uncle has a lot of yellow
shirts and even he doesn't like that
stereotype I'm like then why do you keep
dressing like that he's like I don't
know it just looks good if you can't
complain about it [ __ ] nerd I haven't
talked to him in like weeks like really
yeah I don't know what he's doing that
sucks you should come over again soon or
is scorpion a black guy uh well I
oh [ __ ] agree I'm gonna go hang out over
here by these spikes just for no reason
come over here bud I'm not even playing
yet cuz I'm too busy reading chat I
forgot we were playing a video game
ok collective mind two dollars hey wait
a second this isn't a superhero property
ah I can't deliver governor the game I
was looking away he says hi basically hi
hey hey hey well hey Willemijn
collective man and then he wrote I'm 69
donates two dollars and says Gil what's
up boys it's gamer time and why security
69 was 68 taken her 70 70 taking like
the ideas well I know that upset I took
70 so yeah okay all right I just like
the idea of you set up your account and
then you you just like go through every
single number one by one oh [ __ ] oh he's
doing his own a fatality on himself
what yeah what the [ __ ] haha cutie what
they do that it's weird here do they
still need to send me stuff this is cuz
they're trying so hard to figure out how
to keep this this series like alive
because they were starting to run out of
ideas and they're like okay what if you
can do a fatality on yourself because
you don't want the other person to have
the satisfaction of winning it didn't
really stick has that crispy nick says I
feel betrayed - oh yeah because he was
asking me to put a stream MORTAL KOMBAT
11 with him but I told him I can't cuz
my ps4 is at my dad's house which is not
a lie it actually is over there because
I was playing MKX with my him and my
sister so I mean I can still stream
Mortal Kombat kinda cool I love these
characters who's what [ __ ] on
the planet
his favorite Mortal Kombat character is
Diet roof okay look at him how you doing
dieter title goat a guy died you know at
least scorpions design in this game is
super cool yeah man you know what I
can't wait for backseat gaming because
you only get that in fighting games like
what well okay not only nah mama again
but for streams it's like a lot harder
than most other games do there really I
mean I guess some people have a [ __ ] on
you literally they just say [ __ ] it
you're bad sad that says it's that
simple because they can't just
micromanage you the entire to somebody's
you'll try to it they can't go like ah
why didn't you sleep there you put the
backseat gaming i I see worse in
streaming is either fighting games cuz
like every person who's into fighting
games thinks they're the greatest
fighting games player in the universe
true it's me or survival horror game
because for some reason a lot of people
treat those like okay you have to get
the s-rank run on the resident evil' you
have to beat this playthrough in under
an hour and a half or else you're bad
oh no you walk past one item that wasn't
a key item you're terrible at the game
looking solid that's how it is yeah I
know people want to like turn on your
control right I have to press a button
for that don't they yeah here look
Oh slot Oh block tavius says five
dollars
Mortal Kombat 4 is by far the best in
series how dare you say it's one of the
worst entries Jarek is so cool admit it
I like how Jarek has to make sure that
he tells you he's gay every time he
falls off the cliff
what I'm so gay that's the weirdest
nobody says it sounds like that here's
your controller turned it on it's turned
it on here I will turn on a profile for
you oh [ __ ] I don't know I forgot what
the profile codes are what no I I had to
make them myself
oh great they wag master yeah there you
go
[ __ ] this game okay alright I hope Jarek
is in the next one that we play I like
it when people
get by I like how joke is in this one
huh Oh noob smoke yeah there there one
character I guess like they wanted to
have both of them in there
all right boys I'm kidding I'm picking
the cutest girl austra there he is head
arias yeah he's adorable
Melina's here we're playing milena so I
don't know how to play her I guess like
the whole point of milena dressing like
that is she wants to distract from her
spooky monster face so she's like no
shirt at all all right well since the
d-pad sucks I gotta figure out a place
game you can use the joystick I'm doing
that no I can't
hey beat me up I haven't even figured
[ __ ] out leave me alone ow price I don't
want a button applause oh and I yeah
they're wrong they're just wrong all
right listen uh noob tethered smoke tag
out use your God powers to become an
infinitely expanding evil cloud
oh [ __ ] watch this one no [ __ ] that's um
what I wanted
Oh God go get them okay I'm looking at
the chat and trying to play in it oh
yeah excuses and [ __ ] I knew this
Sun was in my eyes do a patreon voice
chat after coward says there's been a
ban on doing this for a little while I
was thinking about maybe doing that
tomorrow
Oh get out here do with this thing
Melina oh [ __ ] nothing um I hope I don't
fall through the floor
oh that's Josh $10 you're no no you
you're awesome haha I got you go get him
out who'd what the [ __ ] I forgot how to
do combos me too it's all quarter
circles that's what I'm just smoked is
this quarter circle how about this odd
no how about this mohawk hello
oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] up switch out man okay
yeah [ __ ] got him beaten me even though
the d-pad is garbage at least with the
Shaolin monk at least with Shaolin monks
dpad you don't have to use it at all
except for the fatalities so if you can
put in a single input for like up and
down you're fine I'd have just been a -
tech oh [ __ ] what oh my gosh already
said ten hours my bad I got so excited
this video games too violent
Godzilla Mendoza remember that time when
all those housewives teamed up on the
punisher that happen oh yeah it was it
was um all of the wives of the crime
bosses he'd killed for like several
years in the guns and they they wanted
to get revenge and then and then
Punisher on an unrelated note got
kidnapped by another ex-wife of a crime
boss and then tied up and she's like
don't worry I got this because she hated
all the other ones because they were
shitty to her back when the crime bosses
were still alive so she put on his
Punisher shirt and then went and killed
them all for him and then came back was
like hey I did it
he's like a all right I've omitted some
very dark details from that story like
when she shot someone in the head and
then straddled Frank castles nether
region whatever anyway I don't like that
there's also the part that's dekhta mean
no no no okay you're not sub-zero
alright alternatively uh hang out with
your friends after says crispy Nick I
don't have friends I don't believe in
friends Jamie while five dollars hey
Xavier that Rob Liefeld [ __ ] am i right
LMFAO hey man not really
yeah I blocked me on Twitter cuz I say
he was being really mean to someone and
he was being really peeved it's tough
one
oh what a shitty guy and they hang back
well no cause like like 15 or or ten or
fifteen other people have told me like
the same kind of thing happens where if
he if you like don't tell Rob Liefeld
something he wants to hear he'll just
block you oh hey man [ __ ] no how do you
grab r1 oh is it just my god no [ __ ]
stop blocking gets lanced ey josh is so
much better at fighting games cuz he
knows that the ability to block exists
unlike me
ah haha now dude boys donate $20 if I
chain grab him into death no don't know
ha just crouch you'll just crouch [ __ ]
ha ha yoy gay I what the [ __ ] dude [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] ha ha I know alright alright
don't donate $20 I take it back I'm
gonna throw you into the end of the
water and you're gonna get eaten by
piranhas
I don't know how did I use any of his
moves didn't happen oh this game sucks I
hate how do you do fatalities is that no
no it's just not know Xavier you're
awesome man thank you that's not how you
spell your I love you what m'kay is this
one of the bad ones
well I mean like they're all kind of bad
in their own special ways and that's why
I love them kenchi is the only character
from Mortal Kombat 5 that was so cool
that they were just like let's keep him
for the rest of the series she is cool
and she's super cool I'm sad he's not in
MK 11 can she's a [ __ ] bollard I
think he's been he's been in an MK 4
through oh my god okay look speak of the
devil
your ps4 okay I guess we have that now
that's pretty funny now we can play
you
I will don't worry
the elastic King Soopers bags filled
with a ps4 and controllers and stuff oh
god no I'm outta here
alright thanks bye Wow
wow that was nice how nice they actually
like hurt our calls from the ether Wow
neat alright now he's not paying
attention no it was stop it
haha stop it Mike I can which I can't
block that [ __ ] [ __ ] a lot also look I
like how all the characters from MK 5
that they didn't keep are in these these
[ __ ] jail cells over here look look
is that shinnok oh god he's grabbing me
that's funny his henchman Oh what is he
doing
come here you [ __ ] up don't touch my now
that oh look there's Frost
oh god oh this one and this did odd no
metal hazard oh my god now you have the
ps4 I'm gonna bug looks there's like old
scorpion for some reason I'm like too
busy looking at the background to
actually fight alright focus up so I can
kick your ass damn it
Mason said that now that I have a ps4
he's gonna bug me josh is bad at his job
miss a super chip I probably actually
did miss super channel I was too busy
getting a ps4 handle me what the [ __ ] I
have telekinesis [ __ ] I'm a blind
swordsman [ __ ] I don't know what any of
my combos are oh I was attractive ah
nothing's more attractive to me than
girls whipping you across the room with
their god powers was that wise blocked
it oh yeah what's this one
stop how about this one net Oh
[Applause]
headcanon can she is Molina's cousin and
he's just really tired of her [ __ ] cuz
she always bullies in oh you can do a
combo breaker hey guys watch this chain
grab what's this one no [ __ ] stop
look what's this I just got a Glock and
then grab him oh he crouched guy haha
see if I do not do a fatality oh I can't
do a fatality I press l1 you can change
your fighting style okay okay
shoe how in the background Molina have
big teeth alright Molina we have many
but my phone go many big thing any big
thing all right they're gonna go [ __ ]
produce look they're just teasing you
cry wait no no stop it I just like I
have an arrow in my face about some
arrows oh hey what's your favorite show
on the CW or Mac what's this one I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna kick you in
the head repeatedly oh look there's
another super Chad Josh you should read
it oh geez okay vash the ashtray $10
looked up the solicits for a SM 25 and
it said that it will finally answer who
the bandaged centipede creature is only
two months away and I can't wait any
longer why'd you beat me up because your
dick man oh you know cause you [ __ ] I
have a look to mine okay you're terrible
I think I hear Tim no you you why I hate
when the combos have up in it okay all
right
I hate when the game forces me to try
[ __ ] stop okay what's this one one
all right
I'm ready to play something really
volleyball I think look at this yeah do
it again
come on one more time do the thing game
let me do it
it was a way I made it like a ball I
wish there's a mod to just make them do
that pose but extend their middle finger
man hey man [ __ ] you [ __ ] - it suck my
big stupid rat what you dodged it with
your [ __ ] thingy all right yeah oh
god get out of your dick boy
when will you actually review some
Godzilla games I have like all of them
I'll get around to it hang on hang on
hey so Xavier has even Kelly I'm coming
oh ha oh I figured watch some other time
I was waiting for it to get on the on
the Netflix with the with the new dub
that's apparently really fancy the new
dub yeah they're apparently they're
doing a new dub for it's probably gonna
be a Steve eh I can't understand people
who have that much of a problem with the
idea of just we're gonna record it again
in English like I can't there's so many
weirdo elitists who are like subtitles
is the only way to enjoy it let me give
you a perspective alright so I speak
Spanish I'm gonna play ken yeah I see
that that's Ken verse Ryu there he is
yeah Brito here's burn victim victim
he's about a [ __ ] respirator there's
this fan art of Molina we're in that
same pose but she has no shirt on and
all that's covering it is the
centerpiece of the sighs that's great I
like titties anyway here I'm gonna grab
you and you won't miss this one I have
to work now Oh talk tomorrow X who said
that Oh click oh let's collect it oh
thank you so much I had to pause to that
Oh God anyway here's the perspective so
if it's not a Japanese thing it's not
like a animate dude everything is better
in its original content to be honest
like the way it was intended to be made
so when most the time I don't like
fighting styles il-1 oh wait what I
didn't know that yeah I've been I've
told you like three oh you haven't I
have not been cut all the times that I
told him that Ben he's lied Ben he's
lying
grabbed what do I have a weapon
man what the [ __ ] is this you have those
cool hot are those cool hook things have
you seen the what he does with those 11
what the [ __ ] there's no reason for you
to not have them out the weapons are
kind of broken in these older games
that's my blog no that's also why I hate
that it's a button like you can just
hold it you'll be sobbing dumb what's
this what's this what's this
I wish combos were easy you really are
Ken what the [ __ ] you've got flaming one
can we look at my moves like I have if I
have a Hadouken I bet he does he's got
to have something no there's no sure you
motions you know Mortal Kombat games are
there probably are I can't she blasts
hold on alright ready what's this one
what's the [ __ ] what's this one no you
have super speed moves do i yeah like
that's cabal's powers that despite not
being able to breathe he is super fast
stop no it's the 3d era of Mortal Kombat
so I can just sidestep that oh yeah like
a true oh yeah yeah my cat opened the
door again cat literally have to a
fatality pushed me down I'm not editing
if you if I don't smooched you [ __ ] oh
those were some words Benji
no one even watches the stream
highlights despite the fact that there's
some of the best content on the channel
listen watches them it pisses me off
funnier than my normal video Benji I
watched them alright
why he sent me one today that I think is
one of the funniest things that's ever
been on the channel I can't wait to
upload it wait let me see if my parents
have shown up with [ __ ] benadryl oh
yeah you can't touch these cats because
you're deathly allergic allergies yeah
read that why like oh okay I can use my
phone kitty what do you have the kitties
on my lap man I'm gonna die [ __ ] I don't
need some 20 year old white boy ginger
to tell me what didn't work for him in
my decade-long Spiderman run it wasn't
meant for you
oh thanks Dan I appreciate your
contribution so apparently people aren't
allergic to cat fur but they're allergic
to cat sweat cat dander I don't know it
was also raining really hard outside my
window is cracked
I should probably fix that no it's fine
it's getting on my bed hey Xavier its me
the Brazilian fella
oh hi I'm Brazilian beautified me told
me I McGee told something something
soccer joke I don't know does a good one
haha I laughed hey kitty alright guys
it's just me and a kiddie show go away
Xavier is much like a David cage game
out there he only reads chats if you pay
him sometimes sometimes I'll read chats
listen I'm the chat master not Xavier it
depends on me yeah should we switch to
the next game already is this already
that boring well I mean I'm taking your
ass I understand go ahead this kitty is
purring like just vibrating my chest
cavity okay hang on
alright I will hang on hang on a sec
we'll be right back Bob wait do you
think actually I don't think I'll get
copy ready for this one but ready
alright okay I don't know bom-bom-bom Oh
cat out Jesus [ __ ] drooping my [ __ ]
dick with your claws it's a sign of
wanting to really it shows that he loves
dad my peepee
okay wait was the how are you supposed
to know if the cat loves you if he
hasn't like mutilated your genitals
a little bit what the [ __ ] that's yeah
in the animal kingdom that's how they
that's how they assert their dominance
and also show affection ok ready ready
ready watch those horses what oh I was
not enough no hey what the [ __ ] I went
through so much trouble to Google that
sound brada you spent so much time
trying to get the we'll be right back
sound effect just so it could not be
very loud and not ok I'm excited because
we get to see the intro cutscene for
this one put on the headphones okay
alright my games but what is this 2006
yeah it is oh it's [ __ ] ancient I put
these headphones on backwards and this
Kitty is still on my lap an autosave
feature remember one that like autosave
was like scary and like a concept people
weren't used to yeah I had a bunch of
midway games I remember when I was tiny
I liked remember one Midway still
existed alright this opening cutscene is
kick-ass I love it are you watching I
don't know how one of those like guard
guys from mk1 got here but okay so this
game is interesting because do you know
which characters are on the roster
nothing none of them know yeah just like
just just just a couple they even got
the shitty ones deseed I drew and
[ __ ] shoe how and and uh Jax Jarek
they even got [ __ ] Jarek what a nice
guy
I think they didn't get any from the
unless Serena is in this I should check
but uh they even have a couple I think
from some of the the spin-off games I
like how Scorpion and sub-zero who are
known for their like kick-ass
superpowers are just sword fighting
right now and he knows an icy sword it's
fine it's no look there it clears their
shin AK and then there's dark Raiden
okay so in in the intro for the last
game he died cuz that drag
guy like exploded him and he came back
as a ghost zombie and then he
resurrected Liu Kang who's been dead
since MK 5 as another zombie and and
also for some reason Kung Lao can do
that in this intro but never anywhere
else um Quan Chi can summons oh look
Scott OH
no Scott Shao Kahn has been killed off
in the series like five times using that
never seems to [ __ ] stick all right
this is great ready everyone everyone's
confused they're not sure what to do
there this pyramid just came out of
nowhere and they're like what's what's
this enigmatic thing right now [ __ ] that
we need to do more punching [ __ ]
yeah then cabal tries the super speed up
there and they're like nah oh and then
borracho uses his magic super powers oh
I really hate bow right [ __ ] sucks so
bad I wish that uh Cyrax didn't get such
a raw deal in this cuz he just gets
[ __ ] tossed and that's it also like
her Mac has telekinesis why did he go up
there and try to grab her with his hands
but it's wrong with him why would you go
fight someone who's like a foot taller
than you and has forearms
when you have telekinesis just a
question just tripping
seat now there you go good job oh wait
it turns out it wasn't her Mac it was
Shang Tsung who is somehow better being
her Mac tanner Mac is well there's Thor
okay something dumb about this is that
the cannon ending of this whole scenario
is that Shao Kahn wins and like defeats
what's at the top of the pyramid how the
[ __ ] did he get back there oh look oh
this is great
remember me from the fifth game that
character that Ed Boon hates ed buna
hates Liu Kang he's so bored by he's
just like we don't we have to put him in
because he is like expected to be there
but he just like he it's very clear how
you much vastly prefers scorpion and
wishes he was the main character instead
he's still pretty good at martial arts
being like a zombie and all melina my
favorite shoe Jing ko the main character
of the last game one of the most
powerful characters in the in the series
he has like a hundred different
superpowers
he just gets punched in the face and
falls down and we don't see him again no
blaze is a background character from
Mortal Kombat two plays from Sonic the
Hedgehog yeah blaze blaze the cat that
that's what's at the top of the pyramid
ah [ __ ] yeah it's all I want yeah
alright
choose I have a cat on me I can't move
choose a fighter bro you can move I'll
hold these using the cast okay look all
right well if I die it'll be because the
cat is gripping my thigh with its
massive claws I don't know what my uh
right let me play you now a game where
my creative characters on this game
there's cream oh look I made myself when
I was like 12 Ilan what else do I got
the [ __ ] is my vato and why is he such a
baller
um Movado is is back in that that
embarrassing period where they're just
like trying so
to create new characters was this did
I'm a quiet in this game I did or at
least I tried on right
my name is frost and I people oh look
what I made a ninja turtle and then I
changed it to Rorschach like huh what's
this one all right
oh look here's my creative character
original character do not steal
Deadpool Oh see ya
Deadpool gamer girl OC I think I even
like Miss oh my super chat Josh you but
Vash I'm sorry
you know what does it say a dreamer five
dollars all right so I've given up on
giving on getting you to play I'm scared
so instead I want you to enjoy whatever
you play and I will no longer you bother
you for petty things
oh the curse over he said Vash said if
NetherRealm doesn't allow announced skip
Wescott his future DLC character in MK
11 I'm canceling my pre-order I walked
backwards thinking that that would block
for some reason what's this one so in
this game just to kind of like make up
for the fact that they have so many
goddamn characters they they only give
you two fighting styles so it's like you
know like a main one and then and I
guess the fighting style daggers and
then and then a weapon stop do a stop it
stop ah this is high level Mortal Kombat
gameplay alright watch this with style
[ __ ] no I could've juggled me there
mystery I'm good I'm gonna win God [ __ ]
you did I was a boring ass throw you're
a boring ass throat alright hold on can
you just switch places with me real
quick
no wait wait stop it read read alright
we're good it's okay no oh oh yeah yes
so you can oh watch this one oh wait I
don't feel like it anymore how does that
not hit you looked you know you would
have liked some sort of hit my forearms
are strong
I'm like Lok blow hitting how is there
no feet ah what is that ice to my feet I
hope your sub 0 but if sub 0 was a girl
original character do not steal what's
this one what's this one where my other
combo host oh I don't know but I'm gonna
hit you I'm gonna eat you with my big
big thing oh you see outside of the map
oh that's awesome
hold on stop doing huh try to see the
side of the map stop whoa
what am i doing just do absolutely did
it just do a bunch of combos I'm just
just hit a bunch of I'm pressing
everything in the game just just do a
bunch of random pressing everything
possible that's all it would do I
literally press everybody fatality this
one because they have so many characters
they didn't want to make a fatality for
everyone so they have a build a fatality
button so if you just do a bunch of
random [ __ ] combos at the end
it'll just just kind of come up with
something great that's awesome I'm
playing Jade Jade Savior what do you
think of Molina
so as Darth Vader Molina is pretty cool
wait really Darth Vader I didn't like
the real Darth Vader that's awesome
thank you so much I act real Darth Vader
actually like isn't he kind of like a
fascist like like military leader
through for some vampires some base Nazi
I think so oh man Darth Vader get Nix on
watch this wait no well grab again
what's this get off [ __ ] stop that dick
Don stop doing it I don't feel like
getting dick today no hold on hon stop
oh just leave me or you can carve
through it though [ __ ] I want to want it
yeah there we go
no no it's like the hammer in smash bros
oh yeah well I got this [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
y'all hear this bastard oh you have a
staff that Louis I go peace theater man
2099 we got a pause beginning for this
well what's that uh man $25 man I'm kind
of sad I'm hanging out with friends
tonight instead of being with the stream
here's some big money Xavier plus we get
more Josh which is always a good yeah
I'm gonna cry that's the nicest thing of
I think josh is great he's a good buddy
of mine I like that guy - he's okay no
no your [ __ ] [ __ ] bitch-ass dick ass
no ho you're supposed to uppercut okay
if you go to the edges where it has like
a glowing light line you can do like
environmental stuff
oh so you could have knocked me into
that lava if you waited for it to turn
green
that's impressive yeah um it's a little
May okay so they took the shower took
out reptiles designs of Shaolin monks
and I think this is probably his best
ninja design in the series they also got
rain here and I don't I don't like that
they made him look lesson in je this to
me look look it's it's CJ sub-zero ICJ
what the [ __ ] good that papule Bulls
got time for your [ __ ] I'm playing
little May I noticed no elephant's but
I'd like to imagine she's a rapper who's
little may look my roommate my roommate
said hi or no he just asked me if I'm
gay alright I'm gonna stop okay
would you believe this characters and in
MK X sub 0 no yeah no I guy sorry I'm L
totally make oh haha what's this one
what's this one what's this one da Bay
this one I said oh [ __ ] oh yeah me
neither
[ __ ] ah now it is cool alright we're
gonna do it again what this games big
dumb you got any vertical attacks this
way Soul Calibur was a way better game
ah
blasphemer no Baba / yeah how do I do
that that's slide tackle thing yeah
there we go haha that was very
impressive you got one hit on me there
one one round you just you just salty
cuz cuz Sub Zero one with his frosty
hands he you're G note C cuz I'm better
video yeah Jesus Christ I lied it was a
joke it's a joke no no stop oh I have to
get out of here
they're great there should be a handrail
Jesus why is there not
what if an old lady trips down those
stairs man man sub-zero has he's always
got he's always got this same problem is
that whenever he meets a girl it always
goes wrong because he's got such cold
hands
it looks like I'm proposing oh my god oh
yes yes of course Lima yes
oh no oh she black catted me sucked your
dick and left a lot a lot of people do
that now what though oh I mean he thinks
sub-zero's dick is called generate ice
from he's got a very cold peepee way to
take what could have been a really good
bit and ruin it oh wow oh Jesus oh oh no
oh what that just takes the rest of your
health bar uh-huh that's not cool that's
not hey you're disqualified from oral
combat did the cat that's cheating moved
itself form I thought I didn't cat
peeled off of you okay I'll be I'll be
zombie Liu Kang I'll be [ __ ] Moke
I'll be misspelled Dargan the get mug
isn't he a hero he's my hero man there's
okay look it's Kai everyone's favorite
mk4 character or black okay look at this
fellow who was died Kong died gong uh
Nazi Hitler as opposed to Nazi gay bar
Nazi I miss to a I seem to misspoke
there's girl Raiden there's um there's
there's Quan Chi's boss there's a knock
Kratos I like him there's a katanas mom
what um there's Shao Kahn Goro Kintaro
moat are because they didn't want to do
the look they [ __ ] up motaro he's
supposed to be like a like a centaur
with a horse body but they didn't feel
like figuring out how to do the
animations so there's some dumb Laura
thing that like he was cursed to have
his second pair of legs taken and he
wants them back
what a machine Yasir's you meet mostly
goat I take it back and playing God no
skin how do i unselect I'll be I'll be
gay bar Nazi damn it I can unselect and
be meat howdy
sailor fools I'll play do you wanna do
you want to propagate the purity of the
white race cuz I sure don't that's two
hetero for me I got a sword
I don't think offending two different
groups at once very good look at them
it's okay about two perfect you damn it
I died what the [ __ ] I don't know I just
saw like a red line out of my chest I
wish I wish that we were better at this
game it's okay no it's it's it's it's
great in mortal combat this was the high
point of more go away no stand my ground
Stan my just upper cut me over the ledge
already
they always cool as [ __ ] he does all
right Wow okay now I'll just stand over
here near the near this weapon for some
reason get out of here how do I pick it
up how do I pick it up I'm gonna pick it
up no not hitting me really shitty if
these fake - hello good job well the
fatalities just sucks oh it's fine oh
it's great
I made war Shaq and Deadpool in this
game what other characters do I got you
got sector oh hold on I know who to play
as wait hold on oh you can change the
where you want to fight there's so many
memorable hospita hell alright what is
that actually one of them is hell Wow
yeah there we go just oh hell okay oh
look I got Ike him I'm playing with the
the / the good smoke just the other day
us
Katara I think in the other game her
name was Katara and then they changed it
because it sounded too similar to katana
katana fair enough
so now the Atari Spidey central since
two dollars and says what do you say Oh
get it cuz he didn't say anything Oh
what the [ __ ] you fell down it's fine I
don't have my buddy noob here to help me
out this time I feel so empty and lonely
with Athen god stop here you stop slob
squatting my [ __ ] shins off I'm gonna
go pro at this game
watch me I'm coming here I come oh god
don't let them isolate that sound clip
haha
smoking kills or if anything just kind
of invariably like stings you a little
bit in 20 to 30 years your lungs are
[ __ ] dude I win I'm playing the long
game the long con yeah if I don't kill
you
lung cancer will I don't have to beat
you now pi was like oh no just like the
rest of the population
I just have to know he'll be a very sad
old person
okay I'm gonna look at the moves list
cuz [ __ ] you alright fine
alright you get to do it - it's okay I
can but I don't need it
I'm a pro look at this move title I'm a
game the title of this move stinky
fingers I don't want you to do that who
just puts his two fingers up to her nose
and goes hey hey hey you smell that and
she's like oh oh oh you know what that
is you know what that is she's like I
think I know what that is and he's like
huh isn't that funny and she's like no
smoke it's not funny you ass smoke is a
frat boy from college and that's cannon
man not how all frat boys act yeah who
was so approach snow I figured I'd check
Bishop oh you can imagine cyber ninjas
cat doing keg stands I'd be [ __ ] dope
holy [ __ ] we are letting you godless oh
okay what do I got low pause strike no
you gotta go over the
special moves list there you go you can
spit blood I don't think that's a move I
think that's a thing that's cause for
concern I think you should go the
[ __ ] hospital notes are what the [ __ ]
does unicorn kick even mean dude another
question you turn into a unicorn and
then kick me with your hind legs well
let's give it a shot here shall we
what the [ __ ] I guess I did not picture
that when you said única oh look I got
my cool teleport back yeah this shit's
broken on Mortal Kombat 3 you could just
kill everyone with that yeah I know
no stop
what's up kid I need the kitties ha
matching my shin Oh Mike my cat is
distracting you to give me an edge I see
how it is come here you know bottom stop
oh here we go again
come on boy Oh what's this [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
she's got jiggle physics off oh yeah
hold on one just like Crouch an
uncracked really fast
no I goes away all right oh no your
honor now to get her to switch the sides
though I'm pressing every button right
there's a way to switch sides [ __ ] me
I'm such [ __ ] teenagers Xavier whoa
she's got titties whoa don't think me
just kick me while blocking me what I
worked a second ago y'all ready to play
ball did you see those games - oh my god
wait not only do I hurt you but I suck
on your blood stop sucking on me I don't
like it go get him alright well this is
the final moment ah crisis it's not
actually there's plenty of final moments
we still have lots of final moments
feels like those wings are Wanger back
like a decent bed they've counterbalance
for the front I thought you would do
that ah now watch this one no what's
this my robot jaw now watch this [ __ ] no
I don't wanna lose this both spam the
same movie tears is faster it's unfair
we lose I lose how do I make you die of
coughing again I don't know
aha that I think I really don't like the
way that move comes out this waves is
here yeah look and then you just cause
like oh I'm getting secondhand smoke
kills this is a [ __ ] dare i dude ah
hey guess what this is my first hand and
this is my second hand you got it get
slim oh [ __ ] okay I don't want to lose
the oh oh [ __ ] oh yeah oh good okay
alright now just do no wait I don't know
from back here from back here no I'm
coming fire lady just approached just
kicking wildly alright well we left
everyone that's been spamming editors
revolution oh Jesus Christ oh oh dude is
Jacob and Benji or mad for what for why
what did I do
Oh Spidey sent two more dollars he says
Xavier why you so gay because there's a
little bit of gay in all of us use some
kind of kiss you want you want to do
that you want to do the cyber ninjas
match again you could be sektor and I'll
be cyrix alright there you go we got our
race boys here's the plan I'm gonna try
take my cat out can reach out get out of
here this cat is doing giving me so much
love which is gonna give you like it's
the love I don't get in my spare time
oh it's gonna give you give you a hives
I'm gonna start coughing blood I can't
wait oh man both he just his dye just
went directly here it's okay he's got
gyroscopic robot thighs so he can kick
as high as he wants
oh god no but no stop oh [ __ ] I just
want you to ask you if you knew where
which terminal I could get to Oh God oh
these New York subways are always filled
with crime and write of robot ninjas ah
we've got lace with cut like safer yeah
they even have the noises pulse blade
pulse blades I have two you have one I
objectively win oh man I tub too poor to
afford to
what's that one move it has a triangle
in it Oh what don't do that again
no go get him hang on I want to just use
I want to just yeah there we go
oh [ __ ] you do your robot she'll do mine
oh oh you're my robot [ __ ] is cooler cuz
Oh
missiles are fair yeah hey you can't
block that [ __ ] big gay and so am I
what a cool just trip him ninjitsu
minjok wide why don't I have a Ninjago
far does it make me switch back to my
other fighting stance when I lose but
not you oh god oh god
good questions I don't think we should
question the rules this game though oh
no oh I need to get on the other side
you know okay I'm gonna up okay [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh you're not throw you into the
train I'm gonna do it you're gonna get
on that train track it's gonna be great
you ready uh oh yeah come here you know
[ __ ] yeah I'm fine guys it's okay
oh geez looks like you had a train to
catch I'm leaving no joke I'm sorry I'm
sorry we were happy
okay I'm sorry it was just a joke
[Music]
okay
is it working now did I fix it I think I
fixed it nice once I see it alright
thank you the mic for [ __ ] sake man I
was dancing the entire time who wins
uh Anna wins for telling me to fix the
mic cuz I probably wouldn't have if she
is insane it would have been like that
bit in the spider-man streamer what the
[ __ ] that took so much help
oh okay sorry I did when I ran out
that's right I was dead I was dancing
the entire time what wise been screaming
about a revolution in the chat I feel
like I'm think it's mad cuz you started
streaming so us to edit Morgan I mean
he's still got do the x-men stream and
the other spider-man stream hey I like
keeping them busy man Ilan I I hope I
still have all my dumb Kino moves
where's my move I have done five what
the [ __ ] is that
oh no please stop Jax stop okay do an
uppercut right now alright yeah that's
it oh that mmm why did I say anything
oh oh oh why did that happen is what
caused that
oh my limbs just fell on the rats are
taking oh why is his arm still mo i'm so
confused by so many things happening
right now yeah poor guy I I was like
looking at your cursor while hitting the
button on mine look you can play as
chameleon
I'm just Darius dude he looks like a
[ __ ] I'll be the other black guy
dharia slit early looks like a pimp like
just give him the Hat with the feather
in it alright since I have a spare
moment that weird geek $5 says I got my
very first paycheck the other day and I
decided to donate to you since your live
streams have brought much joy fanbase I
think we're so sweet dude Oh God look I
have a hammer I have a troll yellow one
I have a band
[ __ ] no no stay away here I have to I
have the rule is if I get hit by that I
have to leave oh well - gotta leave yeah
I feel like there's so many really bad
jokes I could make right now
do what do we want to make Noob Saibot
Oh white supremacists on top of
everything else is also being voiced by
CJ CJ CJ oh by the way even like it's
specifically the older subzero that's
voiced by CJ so in all of the other
videos whenever noob saibot shows up I'm
gonna have him dub like that again
[ __ ] baller T iron ninja $2 the mic
cut as soon as I sent my first super
chat I'm so sorry I read it we were
acknowledging you and I say he's gonna
like Twitter to open again no all right
I'm not dancing anymore ah
oh hey I pressed that button first Wow
press F in the chat if I don't know
being hard being funny is hard dude I
know especially you get tired if you're
if you get tired
your jokes immediately like either they
get really really bad oh god okay Benji
said redhead one us editors me cheddar
Jacob I don't know why are taking a
stand against you it's about time you
give us editors all more smoochies after
videos and we demand them now Oh tell
him this okay that's like the gayest
[ __ ] I've ever heard all right okay so
okay all right so no more and more
actual pay with like money it's all just
smoochies from this point forward all
just smoochies just smoochies only
smoochie smoochie wall go on all right
watch this one what's this cross up
Darius is like what that was sick
all right now there's that air combat
from the stupid cutscene from earlier
hold on let's try and both do the Oh No
oh do a combo like down like do a
quarter quarter circle square oh it's
like you get off on discipline it's like
you it's like you
did you actually ever send out a tweet
on your tweeter I didn't I should right
do that I'm gonna do that right now I'll
go do that
how do I uh you could play as Drammen
who's covered and flies and then I'll
play is me who is also equally
disgusting it's just too gross guys with
the Europe you're rotting and I mean I
have no skin I look like the [ __ ] guy
from Hellraiser
good call I don't uh it's just the the
Godzilla Mendoza live thing I know but
we're gonna take it to my my channel
yeah and then like look at these two
characters alive see oh okay well no
they'll look at these two characters I
like it's just it's there's something
really uncomfortable about this why does
he have cleavers cuz he's me
I guess that's funny meat cleaver lose
my job ah host ah that's my face
everything hurts
I don't have skin oh it hurts the walk
everything is pain also I love how this
arena just has a bunch of dumb [ __ ]
on every corner there's sir there's a
crushinator here's a [ __ ] acid pit
there's a there's a spike pit there's
lava can I throw you into these things
yeah I mean I'm not gonna say no but you
go over there no no you go over no you
go go over there damnit go away you
gonna stop you what the [ __ ] man see if
around - I'm fine he's fine
it's instant replay of that dog [ __ ]
he's got a he's got a big spinny goddamn
put the block why are my ankle joint
auto [ __ ] Oh what the [ __ ]
I don't like what's happening right now
dude why do you have a [ __ ] waitress
over dude look at the drama and plea and
please please nerf drama he's too tough
that's it
and you piece of [ __ ] look at him dance
dudes they go he's so proud of his
[ __ ] Ricardo meals so matters like
okay you wanna be forearmed lady or for
a man or for our man or for leg man who
only has two legs in this game I'm just
gonna be I'll be Goro remember Goro why
does he have four pectorals doesn't that
mean Shiva should have four tits I'd be
gross look he has four nipples
why does she go have only two look do
you see I see no nipple there's okay you
gotta zoom in a little bit it's tiny
assuming on his tiny nips yeah there's a
little bit of nip going on there
see look he's got four pecs and four
nipples you guys it upsets me it offends
me okay good night steers striker he's
just a [ __ ] cop that's his character
great yeah I've been invited to Mortal
Kombat for some reason I'm one of the
several people on earth that I can't do
a gravel on you for some reason it's
pissing some very strong doctor I want
to get there you go what yeah it's a
move from mk1 that's neat Wow I beat you
with my superior strong and Auggie did
look it is nice
oiled up before pectorals what's this I
want a Mortal Kombat oh my god what the
[ __ ] was that I don't know what huh are
you scorpion stop I've got a Taser it's
a Taser
that's not how Tasers work stuck a taser
hug or something yeah I mean I'm a real
fair character wait I can't grow there's
no [ __ ] handrail oh I can't stop
falling up oh no now he's beating me cuz
he's mad I don't lose except when he
does except for what I do which is never
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] watch this oh the show
con race is a bunch of half-dragon guys
and that begs some interesting questions
about the lore of mortal con
being who [ __ ] a dragon to make those
also who [ __ ] a tiger to make Kintaro
no what is it part of them stay it's a
black hole that's not black that's a
blue hole okay we'll be everyone's
[ __ ] favorite character Fujin everyone
loves Fujin for no reason everyone's
eyes tell me oh don't diss on Fujin
hurting so cool i'm gonna try and read
some chatter for my phone [ __ ] dies
then I can plug it in MK x MK x MK 9 MK
9 MK X everyone's MK X is being spammed
in chat I'm glad that your community and
your fan base has done enough of these
strains that they know how to rally
around each other and spam the same word
that means you've got a committed and
loyal fan base and they they'll they'll
obviously know that spamming stuff in
the chat always works right they also
know that spamming stuff and MORTAL
KOMBAT always works like this I'm gonna
do next stupid flash joke it was a joke
oh did I do that I'm gonna I'm gonna
flail the [ __ ] out of you oh stop no
stay
oh hold on who has big feet they say
about Hotaru's with big feet
they've got big flag know they've got a
Morningstar what the [ __ ] - nah katana
oh my god naginata naginata
Maggie tom agee [ __ ] to you why are you
jumping hahaha you've been smashed into
this identical room we're in [ __ ] PT
ok it's every room is just the same room
Goro Slayer is infinite in all
directions come here you want to fight
you you mean
yeah I don't know how to do any of my
weird scary like crossbows ah hang on
stop give me a second to breathe okay
okay hmm here I come oh [ __ ] with our
ee-vie [ __ ] it's a defense mechanism
yeah you like stay away stay away you
want more of that
oh god how do I do that again it's
retaliating well I know how a rocket
legs project corpse time shadow a chaos
axe kick ah I don't like it it's bad
perfect
oh you just shoot acid out of your hands
light on my feet his hotaru feet oh I
[ __ ] with the [ __ ] motion hey my
knees oh god did you see that look
Oh havoc scary
he's cyclopses big brother who dies oh
why do you never try and punch me after
a juggle mister I don't know that's my
kneecaps I need those away now I don't
I'm having Oh doc went for a grab and
press the switch place down but ha no
but stop so cake Savior give me a break
your death will come soon no [ __ ] you
ah [ __ ] what's this one nice what's cool
move I good for you look it was all
bruised he's got bruises I look a lot
cooler um okay well you don't call me
crazy but I feel like it's funny that
they put these two characters right next
to each other who knew Jackson who Chi
you trying to say something by putting
these two together what are you trying
to say I don't know anything I don't
know you joke now if to really go for it
you'd have to put Jade there I guess
Jada's kind of black but kind of not
it's confusing
xavier lot year black like someone look
here Sonya with her weird character
model from 2002 that they did not update
for this game at all hey look it's they
just Rosie all of these oh god that huh
that's so cringy and embarrassing I just
remember it's sometimes I've seen in the
trailers it doesn't sound like she knows
how to voice act - I agree it's it
sounds perfect stop you sounds annoyed
stop putting [ __ ] athletes in things
they're not good actors look at this
lightning okay WWE people sure but like
cuz their activism oh yeah they have to
they have to do stories they have to act
right they also do their own stunts very
well but like come on stop don't put the
shacking things the shopman me oh god I
hope there's not another staircase Oh
God
Oh will you cut it out with that can I
not do that I'm gonna grab you and do
some cool why doesn't Moloch have a cool
bottle yes that stop he's got big vegans
you know he's the sub-bass character of
mk5 so he's like the girl of that one
okay slamming ground
ah stop God uppercut me into the [ __ ]
fence already I know you wanted all
right just do it okay just do off stop
you do it no you keep blocking oh my god
I hope he has health insurance always
the [ __ ] stairs man it's the greatest
killer of the Mortal Kombat universe's
stairs Oh God what's this one he's gonna
fatality me I try I just it doesn't work
I just Oh or I'm gonna play as mocap the
greatest hero all right
okay mocap isn't he cool alright we'll
finish it off with not see him
look at how angry mocap is mocap is so
[ __ ] pissed he's ready to unleash his
Ray's motion capturing an angry guy he's
more active than most of the other
characters he's really excited oh boy
well really happy to be here guys oh man
is that one of your signature moves
that's really impressive
Imoh capped at the I'm mocap doll your
moves I studied all your moves baby I
studied all your moves
what haha oh [ __ ] you fell into one of
those girls ready fire legs alright
we're gonna do some quarter circles
ready the [ __ ] was that even even your
moves are flamboyant you look at that
guy and tell me he likes chicks you look
it in look it look it I'm gonna hide
behind this [ __ ] post these hitboxes
are dumb no dude again me alone stop it
come here I'm not interest why does it
works out like Adam [ __ ] come on I'm
not interested he said he wanted to date
you yeah not every gay guy wants to date
you mocap you [ __ ] narcissist not
you're like a six at best mocap yeah
take off the suit and we'll see oh [ __ ]
all right ready ah I did a move is that
good are you proud of me no I'm not
proud of my something I did something
all right [ __ ] you I'm gonna I'm gonna
disown you okay wicked uh who else could
we play as for shitpost
bah bah [ __ ] posts and giggles green and
why did I say look it's Cobra oh this is
the red boy aka Ken um who's the
dangerous dark people you got Goro you
got Quintero blah female characters
together all of them Oh Serena that
goofball look at her body now look at
Serena Serena Mirage sir immortal has
escaped from [ __ ] mortal
yeah immoral makes really angry smiley
smiles and flexes then collapse and
walks away them in the most cute way but
I want that's my head Canon is that that
Serena's personality she's just a dork
she's just super goofy and bad at her
job as a henchman I can parry [ __ ] haha
this is what happens when we we start
like actually like trying to play oh
[ __ ] the the commentary goes way down
yeah I know we try hard a bit too much
look at her you're a trihard oh yeah
[ __ ] you oh she did the Melina fingers
oh yeah the Melina thing where she like
grabs her boobs and is like I am sexual
when she stands up I agree that's
exactly the name okay eleven puts
everyone in clothes and now people are
mad about it I'm mad I'm very mad why do
people have I wanted to see scorpions
ABS goddammit well that was sick Oh oh
[ __ ] Oh oh my god you're doing like cool
shadow moves stop I want so you can't
complain about moves cuz I hate you have
the same moves I do [ __ ] oh nice I'll
do the come get me [ __ ] tactic see just
whenever you come close I'll just hit
you oh that's a really good tactic good
work it works on the bosses what an
undignified way to fall down just face
down ass up or I'm moving the sticks in
every direction that's not working it's
fine I got it so go said it wasn't an
effective tactic yeah [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I'm
too fast you're too fast or one of us
has to fall onto that spike thing okay
can we agree on that
alright let's ship it's not gonna be is
it gonna be me or is it gonna be either
gonna be Serena or is it gonna be Serena
I was really good yes yes do it ready
yeah
Oh God chat board with this stream yet
alright well probably 40 people have
left
oh no oh alright let's let's do m'kay
10 I would have to set up the the
PlayStation 4 well do m'kay let's play
Shaolin monks alright
Shaolin monks blowing chunks
blowing chunks maybe or beat me to it
here Xavier for stealing my future
content and look here's look may our
studios
it's not about spider-man it's about
literally any fanbase I think that video
has been made by more people in Xavier
if I'm entirely honest I like has a
personal connection to how much he hates
people who like that like hello Naga is
so [ __ ] big okay
that's actual size 2 on the look at how
big he is compared to normal size guys
sektor aren't you guys happy that I
interact with you and Xavier interacts
with his fictional action figure
characters make me happy at least they
love me Shu Jenko which translates to
protagonist what a brilliantly named
cure [ __ ] love shujinko [ __ ] oh he's
so cool Jack's dad spent a whole game
being an idiot for like 50 straight
years oh no guys too big for smash liked
the game or like to have sex with to
smash could you try and smash Onaga wear
it all up and wall smash Onaga but I
have to play Johnny Cage let me see if I
can find a behind it he's behind the
wing I found him he's next day he's
texting boat cap it's funny to me that
their own Agha is so big he covers up
half the [ __ ] character select screen
I'm still a little pissed from the mic
cutting alright iron
I said I'm making a Twitter for you I'm
really impressed with your edits I love
you
you've been ignored it's my supposed to
be the tough one
stop really talking stop it whatever oh
na guy was just really whiny
oh stop it I'm gonna grab you they've
grabbed you I was a really impressive
throw it's like oh my god what the [ __ ]
that's a move yeah just got some blank
yards it's just a quarter circle or it's
just a quarter square and then and then
that oh my god why can't I grab you
you're too big I'm too big to be grabbed
are you serious I am the man handle it's
[ __ ] Lee I'll grab on you just cage
so [ __ ] boring in this game okay just
do something so much cooler and the
other ones like the later ones
okay so Johnny Cage is like the the
[ __ ] Jar Jar Binks of the early games
and then an MK like 9 through 11 he's
super awesome ah stop
I got you watch this X square X square
Oh
triangle triangle quarter-circle combos
that are ads in my big slow lumbering
f-fat dragon hands look at him look at
how hot he is just look at his [ __ ]
anime hair [ __ ] animation
no just like Leon s Kennedy Johnny
punched the dragon guy in the nuts
punched him in his Dragon Ball alright
winner 707 didn't donate but I'm gonna
read this thing have you seen the new
Godzilla king of monsters TV spot if no
if so what do you think of it uh if that
came on like the past couple of weeks
then I probably haven't seen it I should
try to do that at some point soon look
it's it's quan chi's everyone's favorite
character squash mean alright do you
guys want us to switch to Shaolin monks
now you're asking for him to turn like I
would have to set up the whole
PlayStation 4 it's gonna be kind of a
you have to be wouldn't the capture card
and all that yes I have to plug it in
all kinds of things wink
no one can see but I'm winking oh it's
just is that is that your clever joke
Josh look man look man look man I'm
trying my best here I'm trying my best
to make sure your fan base feels
interacted with no getting Josh
this boys Josh you remember that time
when Sonya crushed Quinn she's nuts
Josh you're some kind of [ __ ] nerd
hey mk9 if he can't do access what
they're saying do you I don't have the
the complete edition that has all the
extra stuff great
Dead Space extraction oh god oh god what
a terrible game not m'kay extraction
suave Katya let's play Silent Hill 2 on
my morale common why don't we just sing
the entirety of the what do you call it
high school musical thing High School
Musical song I've been dreaming stars
how about that no you're my feelings yes
you're right
I am very it's a large one not it's a
larger breast even your fat are you
playing look phone I'm plugging in my he
read the chat they're gonna hate us if
we're not coddling them and I have to
cover them ok that's my job the reason
that boy is such a pansy is cuz you're
always calling him glad listen man he's
got to grow up on his own and learn that
the world's not as all your own a place
you're such a dick you don't give any
affection I don't need to give affection
to my son
you guys can't tell what we're standing
standing over each other in yellow
berries we're standing very tall right
now to fan out of whatever that was
someone do fan art of me calling Xavier
big penis someone do fan art of Josh
being but please don't wrong doesn't
mean plan it means we want to know what
that would look like look I'm good at
fighting games I just suck the peepee at
Mortal Kombat why I've been saving my
ass a whole shitload of time every
target look in the sky is grey
the Sun was in my eyes man I hope all
the noise of me trying to plug in this
[ __ ] PlayStation wasn't setting the
stream on fire they all except me no
one's you know what yeah they're also
every all 118 people of chatter on
subscribing that's ok Josh can you plug
my Twitter since my first super chat was
cut off because the mic well I don't
know man that's not my call man I don't
even have a Twitter I can't plug you
hate my job I'm just here to give you
some love and attention alright ok Jamie
you're just considerably worse than Josh
oh well yeah [ __ ]
alright well here I'm gonna try it while
you do that I'm gonna try bullying me
I'm gonna try and guys here I'm gonna do
this oh [ __ ]
what are you doing no just sharing your
thing don't do it why not cuz it will
work it will know all right to send it
else into myself no what are you doing
stop don't touch it it'll be fine you're
doing Evil's
I just I just opened your facebook you
dum-dum
I don't want everyone know that I have
that now they're gonna all friend me
like a bunch of [ __ ] oh yeah if you
tell them that don't worry
as the Mortal Kombat's working shooting
for the stars
and some thumps aw mm I don't know what
you're doing you're singing that song
from high school musical
one can you get out of my chair no I'm
sending a message so you can plug it you
plug it into your Twitter let me go yell
at my stepdad about playing with the cat
outside really sorry about him I love
you guys oh [ __ ] he's back
hi Dan hello Mason with my face I'm not
playing with it I'm just sending a link
is strictly professional I don't believe
you you're a dick
no you're wrong Yura that I don't trust
nobody nobody trust me okay I'll get the
game going you do that you can like
content look I'm just trying to get your
[ __ ] there's a demo for the suffering
too in here the suffering - yeah what
the [ __ ] is the suffering - are you
sending this dream tears to make sure
that it works with the link so that way
if it works
Twitter hi Josh reply to this I do not
want to this is not my facebook I said
it's strictly professional play the demo
for the sub early doesn't work being a
dick play the demo well he set up your
speed I set up your things get out of my
chair no you stand yeah I can't fix this
if you're from Stan's get out of the
chair no I'll do it you're not doing it
yeah I got lap then [ __ ] you what the
[ __ ] oh gosh oh my elbow oh god ah I
know I'm coughing I think I just choked
on my saliva on the way down we got an
injury really bad I can't be
a fighter man with an elbow that's
busted Oh like what the [ __ ] is
happening and now on a mission sure so
scream if I'm not good at this game it's
because of my elbow injury and nothing
else that's true that's true Josh Reed
more of Xavier Facebook messages alright
no don't actually I said no I won't read
it I want to just play games and play at
places of suffering do demo oh you feel
like you've just lost control of your
whole life no just like you have no
autonomy anymore I are you okay why is
it taking you so it's not working okay
look if I paste this look I'll work
alright we're good okay
it's look it would paste like this big
long error message alright [ __ ] chair
fine I like how you had to be really
slow about getting heavy I was trying to
fix something you did it did it work is
the day saved almost I'm gonna put a
lock may see this works Oh where's my
controller I want to just see like as
soon as all that whole bit started with
you like [ __ ] around with that the
the chat like just starts just all
getting angry then the stream analytics
just the the it just spirals straight
down oh good job
that got us a more viewers read alright
if your doesn't drink I think both my
parents and my girlfriend are in the
chat that's good that's really good oh
is this the classic clattering all that
yeah this isn't this is just an options
thing in a Shaolin monks let's see if
this one's [ __ ] playable
ah they're just a like no it's not input
lag I just suck all I can even lie about
it I gave you an out just now and you
didn't take it no I'm sorry I'm not a
liar I forgot how to do things true sir
least the arcade version is is it yeah
cuz it's [ __ ] impossible the
difficulty is insane literally just copy
oh god process haha I did the spear move
[ __ ] baller you don't pay me enough
for this [ __ ] shitty ass job I'm
tired of living in the basement I demand
more cookies in less dr. pepper okay
that's right your entire everyone who
does [ __ ] for you they're angry now
because I pay them in an only dr. pepper
and some and not enough not enough
smoochies that's like what they said
[Music]
mouki get my ass guitars the toast Minh
the toasty I'm seriously so bad at
Mortal Kombat I'm this one's kind of
playable oh my God he's not reading all
my button inputs and just reacting
accordingly
oh god I'm still gonna lose though cuz I
suck ah
[ __ ] don't feel of moves more often Oh
what there were spikes on you you just
had to look uh playing you okay let's go
all right put me in all right put me in
the game I'm behind Freddie someone I
don't know who I'm playing plays um oh
hi Oh we'll do it later
no we're beaten do it no we don't listen
to chat
sometimes it's my job the challenge of
both Waterville playing a game Oh what
are you gonna do no get out of here
discord server boy I'm working on stop
trying to help
Oh God oh jeez can someone get him a
link Mason get him a link to the discord
help him out buddy
oh jesus that was terrible well here
here I come cuz the one in my
description probably [ __ ] expired
again even though I said it to never
expire it always expires like after a
day oh oh I did a teleporting you can't
catch a minute okay will you cut it out
aha no no my fatalities
oh um screen size mm I do not think that
disease oh oh look oh I don't like that
oh yeah I don't like that oh no hope it
stop it I can fix that all no stop now
they can get a real topic close-up look
on the action where can i this isn't a
moves list I did it fatality
oh [ __ ] my benadryl is here yeah my
drugs have arrived okay so for those who
don't know Josh is deathly allergic to
cats and I have three cats which means
that every time he comes here he's got a
got to get some benadryl or else he's
gonna just suffocate to death on the
oxygen because it's been poisoned I
guess I'll try to read the chat while
while I wait for him to go get that
should have rolled screen sighs fatality
shrink it until Molina gets squished I
have five cats take that wall fluffy Cod
bunny it's not a contest okay what's my
favorite Godzilla monster besides
Godzilla um can I say space of Godzilla
actually I don't know um
bio lanty is pretty neat are you gonna
review m'kay legacy yes I would like to
owe $2 donation from AJ Bedard thank you
so much sir when are you going to do
another web of shadows stream oh it's at
some point well Anna if he just drinks a
lot of dr. pepper it'll it'll it'll
it'll cat it'll cancel out cuz one's an
upper and the others a downer if I
thought of updating that scorpion
cosplay I have indeed I actually would
like to do that soon I want to do a
couple of non spider-man cosplays at
some point so oh hi you've been able to
take your loss drove us those drogas REO
KS muy importante para la salud Camilo
store discarded es todo so that doesn't
make sense none of that is it's close
but it's not quite there what am I
really like it like a native speaker of
that language or something shut up don't
AJ Burnett bed rods already well oh he
did it again oh he made me wrong you've
done it three times uh MK vs. DCU is
also on the list Oh what's an SI
vocalist ones you read that one is there
any my daughter other game franchises
you would like to make a retrospective
love your vids bro oh thank you so much
I think I would like to do one on the
more uh the Resident Evil series
actually man I would [ __ ] love to do
that - that would that would be a lot
for I actually played the original
Resident Evil One and - and
remakes of both of them recently like
just back-to-back all four games I'm not
good enough to play old I've been trying
to play older games for a while it's not
very good
Josh drugs are bad sorry guys uh anyway
you want you want please please go Leo
spit Nando's see I don't know what this
retrospective mean okay it's like it's
like I'm back it's like it's like you
turn around and like look behind you and
you're like that was pretty cool that
thing that's behind me or you go man
that was some dog [ __ ] you know oh yeah
that too
look at play co-op with a K yeah
Resident Evil retrospective would be
really fun to make actually hold on no
let's do a little bit of verses cuz I
want you to get used to playing oh what
the [ __ ] they're locked oh that's fine
I'll just play I'll play why is Baraka
unlocked for no reason
cuz two dollars again from AJ Bedard
Thank You AJ Bedard for continuous
donating two dollars repeatedly okay you
can say something with those if you want
are you gonna do an infamous or
prototype retrospect if there's not
enough infamous stuff to really look
back on your video I someone actually
did request that on patreon so I'm gonna
get around to that at some point so
trying to figure out if I'm gonna do
that as three videos or just one big
video I feel like after I've played
through all of them again I'll figure
out how much I have to say look this
cutscenes cool this is just like let's
do a recap of everything from Mortal
Kombat 1 but all at the same time what's
cool by the way that's CJ sub-zero
that's the old one so yeah they're like
every every person's fighting their
rival from that game basically um also
it's kind of weird how stuff from this
is sort of cannon I know it was bad this
is real bad luck with smokers oh god I
don't like that how do you get off how
do you get out of there
he's fine he's fine it's fine it's just
a scratch I'm protagonist is that
protagonist no that's that's Shang Tsung
but he's an old man
and then um what's funny is that like
Mortal Kombat 9 despite coming out
like six years after this still has
stuff like kind of implying that this
game is canon like when uh Kung Lao
shows up in that game much like this one
he's disguised as one of those those
guards in the background with the the
black and white masks hmm it's kind of
funny how just to like put you in the
setting of this is Mortal Kombat 2
they're just like okay let's reenact
everything that was really major from
the first game but all at once it's just
every fight that happened individually
let's have them all be there in the same
time ha so yeah Kung Lao shows up he's
cool he's it's implied he might be Liu
Kang's really jealous cousin but they
won't actually cop the saying anything
about the lineage it's really confusing
this game looks dope but you're doper
aww thank you Jake from from forms forms
firms firms oh look at the thing Wow Oh
God impressive very impressive I kind of
wish we got to see older subzero get
mega kilt in this cutscene cuz that's
he's supposed to get Killa fied I did
the thing he's fine I like how he just
got a big like chest wound and now he's
okay my head Canon now I'm probably
gonna repeat this in the retrospective
so if you hear me say this twice shut up
my head Canon is that Mortal Kombat
characters have to have some kind of
light healing factor to be able to take
some of the punishment that they do and
here's why I think that makes sense
light well okay yeah come on but the
reason I think that makes sense is
because that oath C's got four nipples
look again the four pectorals two
nipples won't add 40 but then Achieva
just has two boobs yourself ah before
you finish your statement what okay
I think Mortal Kombat characters have to
have some kind of healing factor and the
only reason that they have to kill each
other in such extraordinarily elaborate
ways is because that's just what you
have to do to successfully kill an MK
character like
in that case the fatalities aren't
excessive they're just like that's what
you got to do now I like the idea that
they're just stupid excuse just they're
just bad thank you look I don't need to
cut him in half 15 different ways I can
only do a one yeah I mean I like it that
they just like [ __ ] people up and okay
all right sir rabies like yo guys we got
to get out of here the island is
crumbling and then we fall into a hole
huh yeah impressive you guys think mocap
will make it to MK 11 I sure hope so
Julie much I've got a taco box
downstairs you're like that your mom's
just try to communicate with this this
game's fatalities Ross okay yeah so
here's what's cool I'll grab some later
thanks Julie is uh the reason okay so
like you got a game like splatterhouse
with pretty cool finishing moves but you
can only do like two of them to each
enemy type really in this one you get
ten per character and you have two
characters so it's way harder to get
bored of them oh there's a that's cool
someone's car alarm is going off outside
huh thank you for hitting the off button
on that whoever you is I hope they're
okay I wish with it's not a bad
neighborhood
oh look at wow thank you I don't think a
car has been great and Wow there's no
dialogue anymore I miss all of it
because you perfect it this game alright
so you play God of War it's like that
kind of haven't played enough the
original God of War I mean we did that
one day we just played it okay the week
that Brendan was over I played so many
games that were on my [ __ ] list like
[ __ ] will you turn off the map I
don't know how I did it um oh my god all
right so you got uh you got jump is X
I'm broke leave this [ __ ] ready already
got light attack you got strong attack
you got fast attack I guess I don't know
oh jeez you'd like slap my ass
I don't want shaggy in Mortal Kombat 11
that would be dumb he can't do any
fatalities cuz he's a children's
character and they don't want to create
brand
I don't see a problem they put him in
the anime fighting game yall [ __ ]
or like or ado do i do a crossover game
with DC oh no you can't have Batman
cutting someone and I would cop there's
no blood in it it's bad guys look at my
combo [ __ ] I dropped my [ __ ] combo no
I didn't I'm amazing then if you are you
hit r1 and then one of the other buttons
you do a do a kick-ass move
look what yeah hold on Ilana I gotta
wait for it to charge back up the sound
of the gods here I come
they give you a lot of enemies to just
[ __ ] yeah I mean this way like it's
not hard at all but it's no okay wait it
will be later this is they're just
giving us a lot of enemies that are
really shitty to just wail on for this
first room so that we'll know how to
fight right but like look at this combo
system could give my combo would not
believe how hard some of the bosses get
later I believe you it's awesome just
funny cuz look like how are you ready
here we go here we go here we go here we
just keep doing it man look amigo if
awesome how they managed to give you
like two on one boss fights that feel
fair cuz you fight like reptile later
and that boss is really hard or or you
you have a you fight a raka and he can
like do moves that hurt both of us at
the same time like he'll throw me into
you or something cool did you know that
drama and Moloch from that other thing
are the same species is whatever these
guys are remember those guys remember
those memorable characters Moloch and
Dromund I know you is there your there
your mains for several consecutive games
everyone loves Moloch and Drammen slap
them around baby let's go let's just
kill all the enemies so that we can
finally leave this [ __ ] room this is
a brain-dead enough game that I can keep
reading chat let's go yeah or I'll just
punch this guy well I bet you jackal
while I read this right just giving it a
good tapping left trigger and input
square up left r1 left right squared
release left trigger
to finalize code unlocks scorpion oh I
mean I haven't unlocked in the in to
play in like the the story cuz I played
this before but I what is there is there
a code unlock all the lock characters
for versus mode that be new it looks
like looks that way
come with me okay you must perform a
block to progress you got a block okay
so you hold l2 and oh we got turned the
game volume up okay hang on it's really
I sorry I didn't I should have said that
better I've headphones on how about that
yeah chat you do it no not really
okay hang on how about now oh here we go
here we go all oh here goes I didn't
realize the game was that quiet I'm
sorry I don't have headphones on like I
I do and it still doesn't make a
difference I feel kinda well okay well
that's cuz OBS is the thing that it's
running through like the audio that
you're gonna hear is different than what
they're gonna hear that's true
what is the worst game you've ever
played winter 7:07 asks trying to think
of like not just like badly put together
I mean it's like it had to have offended
me like I'm so mad that this game
yeah I don't know we got to perform a
block to progress and you keep just
mashing the I'm sorry I'm having fun
listen are you guys you gotta stop
smashing that okay just look I block see
now we can get off oh can I slap him
around now [ __ ] this game look look Liu
Kang look out behind you look out behind
you wanting noises oh that was rad good
for him
Xavier why do you think the Resident
Evil franchise resin evils [ __ ]
awesome I have almost all of them except
for like some little weird side games
but some of us are totally good like I'm
you're so super good I have it I haven't
played again everyone copies of it
actually for what console I have it for
my xbox 360 and my ps4 well I mean it's
like [ __ ] yeah looks like a really good
game like a lot of stuff from the
Resident Evil games are similar like a
UI wise and like some of the tank-like
refinement
I've got a 35 hit combo don't let it
work no one hit Cabo how do we good just
man what do you even need me for all
I'll just let you oh oh oh oh my god Oh
BAM slam getting achievements for that
no I already got 250 like forever ago
okay can we leave yet right hand I have
raiden raiden why one over here will you
[ __ ] I'm picking up a stop stay playing
with skulls and come over here there we
go
air combat okay we can do you know we
can fight I figured out the air combat a
while yeah here we go
also I think you can just do like a
super hard uppercut if you press L or R
one and triangle I feel like this is a
really cool way to make the Mortal
Kombat like you know the style of
fighting translate to a 3d game because
one you know they actually give you a
[ __ ] dedicated jump button unlike the
other two games that tried to make
Mortal Kombat in 3d they didn't just
take the same controls and then be like
okay that should work right Wow
I can't wait to the part where we get to
do the fatalities cuz god are they
excessive slapping round Xavier this
guy's getting nudged into a corner
bullied when will there be an injustice
Marvel game ever I've been trying to get
your attention for a hour please listen
hey I put some fan art up on Twitter for
you and Anna's anniversary and it seemed
to like it
oh I if I haven't seen it yet I'll I'll
retweet it later I haven't been looking
at Twitter much today cuz I've been
trying to get ready for this stream but
I will I promise I'll check it out later
cherish Adrienne I can't read from here
and then [ __ ] that's not the word um
ayyy
he's studying for his chemistry exam man
okay lucky young you get some weapons
Marty try oh those are actual weapons
let's get some rock look I cut him in
half
okay don't fight this guy I want to do
it ready stop I was already pressing
buttons no stop you're not I'm sorry
alrighty ready nope no get back here
you're all grabbing can i job yeah there
we go
nice job on to come that house I did
once the proud of myself you got you can
pick up a weapon too you get this scythe
thing grab it oh ok no not the skull
decide couldn't pick it up until your
teleporter you [ __ ] go get it's right
here nice alright let's go go off to do
more murder anti is art and we all know
it infinite know something says don't
ignore me I'm not hey Xavier I already
asked this bow are there non comic book
games do you like besides mortal comment
will he ever think about doing a video
on that um yeah I like I said I want to
do maybe a retrospective on the Resident
Evil series I think my favorite game of
all time is dead space I also quite I
quite like Uncharted I was pretty into
halo for a pretty long time but then
later I stopped being as into it by the
way this is a stage from Mortal Kombat 1
bike oh look there's even funny [ __ ]
flying around in the background near the
moon was that I don't know there's some
funny [ __ ] here we go
grab him I don't feel like the only one
just just slicing through both my things
in his face after i've yeah you can grab
them now that i have killed all right
let's go
great we're going on an adventure to
caught up as many poor little creatures
as we can [ __ ] rocketship zoom look
there's something by the moon and then
nothing shows up lines fine do you want
in coop platforming is such a goddamn
train wreck
you're my thing come on we got a meet
reptile reptile in this stage in Mortal
Kombat 1 that's why he appears here it's
a cool Easton spider-man have a
character arc aside from his origin yeah
well for one learning to forgive himself
for the Uncle Ben thing he's not guilty
about that anymore
like people think he's always hung up on
that but he forgave himself for like
cornered issues ago or I mean like
there's also that in coming to terms
with the death of his parents there I go
all my sword broke weapon degradation
yeah Oh another phone call did the audio
break again that's okay I am protecting
you guys [ __ ] I can't why are you
falling don't worry guys I got it oh god
they're bugging me for the discord link
okay fine I will get it Jesus our mods
died can I pick you up and throw you no
damn it Santa Claus is driving around
the back oh [ __ ]
alright let me try and get the discord
linked my computer is gonna crash from
trying to do too many things at once
it's fine it's fine
check this all right hold on hold on I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna keep reading chat
while you do that don't worry
josh is a hero got a read chat all right
Xavier to you what makes a great
character um that's a hard question yeah
it is really hard I mean I don't even
think a character has to be necessarily
relatable I find a lot of characters
very interesting oh no hell no there's a
lot of characters that are just really
great characters because they're [ __ ]
wacky Oh crazy
alright let's see if this works hang on
I don't know guys I think there's a lot
of character writing that goes into it
David I'm not reading your stupid-ass
fanfiction I'm sorry I can't all right
hold on I'm gonna do it don't be
surprised next time you go to air yo
Dischord link Oh
crispy Nick says cough Josh just tell
Xavier to give me admin in the discord
you had it already Josh say Lou and have
it on the highlights man that's not up
to me I could say that Ben is the one
who has the deciding of Ben Ben has the
power you could say who Ben's gonna cut
it out yeah this neat guy it'll be like
a song maybe this cool fella I like
whatever he's doing what a nice guy what
a nice fella what a nice young man
okay we get to do fatalities now should
I pull up the the fatality list oh my
god good luck oh god she want me to use
my phone no no hon maybe you should make
a video on metal Metal Gear Rising
revengeance it's amazing I've heard that
for many people dude me too a source
like like the little that I've played
it's one of the wackiest most crazy fun
games I've ever played okay we can do
you've obtained the fatality
don't just say quick I don't want to I
don't want to have to figure out which
one's a quick attack and which one's a
heavy attack just tell me what the
[ __ ] others perform combos to build
up the fatality oh yeah you got a whale
on them for a little while and then
what's that red thing next door a health
bar fills up then you can do a fatality
massacre I think she is riveting
gameplay way too much [ __ ] drinking
right now and I'm with the stunner okay
now now do the thing that pops up it'll
disappear after a while if you're too
slow about it it's easy all right
ya did oh why why did you oh I got all
right you know what all the yeah you
know I usually it's just square I don't
feel like okay there's your fatality
list there's one okay hold on I want to
do one to let me fight the dudes so I
can just love on my fatality who's
laughing you're all grabbing I'm not
slapping just hold them down so I can
okay room at you bud there he goes I
just kick him off screen easy damn it
you're not supposed to explode I mean
I'll get him I'll go [ __ ] came to want
okay there we go wait wait stop I'll try
to throw him at you no you're not
helping he's two days to do fatality Oh
God um um oh [ __ ] oh I didn't make mine
pop up on the screen I thought it would
it's fine just came up whoa no no I
wanted to uh sucks the stream is bad
this stream sucks I can't even subway
guy [ __ ] last dude
everyone's gonna subscribe after this
dream that's true I couldn't do this for
tality Josh for MK 11 thanks that'd be
nice
look there's mance throw dudes they're
eating their own because they're savages
they're just hungry
I'm gonna do a fatality on on that one
see that one over that yeah oh [ __ ] the
other guy already did
we've been spotted spotted snake you
better get your ass on don't make them
mad
I'm sorry you sorry you're fired
you can uppercut them onto spikes I
think a seat okay ah ha ha I did it what
the [ __ ] yeah that was necessary was
[ __ ]
oh I guess agree with the sentiment I'll
scroll up a little on this page so you
can see what yours okay do want to your
own now okay wait I got through this guy
I like throwing guys you gotta throw
guys to please progress through the next
area I did that way faster than I
thought I wouldn't okay okay punch him
and then do one of these fatalities okay
all right okay
quick ask left up right right squit oh
you gotta do a fast ass [ __ ] predict I
know he's got sharp teeth in it so I
would have heard my be good at it no man
I feel like messing with enough practice
I feel like Molina has eventually had to
figure that out particularly sexually
active with up with Baraka oh yeah okay
that's canon no and also Tonya the the
yellow ninja lady oh yeah mm but in
secret oh no Baraka someone's gotta tell
Baraka so he's gotta break the news to
brother kind of a walk in the nudist of
rock checking memory card ps2 thankfully
I can't change the names of the save
files on this game so I can't put it as
something embarrassing I'm subbing and
subbing to Davidian oh wait Davidian
isn't David
that's how that's held little people
look at his channels he hasn't been
named that for like a year and a half
names cautiously real now that's right
that's true people don't love David you
know I wouldn't mind sexing with milena
see that's not the problem the problem
is that think she'd have a lot of
trouble sexing with anyone else
all right so no no no I go oh [ __ ] you
activated the pot bill up here oh no oh
no oh god I'm sorry I was a joke
oh god I walked into the spikes trying
to deal your dumbness okay we'll beat
the oni warlord watch this doorman to
the spikes they throw him like this
oh yeah he kind of fell it happened
eventually oh no what you do is you stay
at a distance and just shoot fireballs
up his [ __ ] like he stammers just
like that yeah have you heard about that
dumb [ __ ] no everyone desperately wants
Thanos to be defeated by ant-man
shrinking going and then and then
growing to 60 feet tall so it rips him
in half that's genius
happy no but even the Russo brothers are
getting into the jet like the directors
are getting into the joke and making
like jokes about it on Instagram like
their profile picture is a Venn diagram
that's purple
and it's on one side it's Fanus is left
but she fan butt cheek and then in the
middle it's just a picture of Ant Man
yeah okay left up square I did I do it
you did it I hope it's a cool one but
it's terrible I think it's the one where
there goes testicles oh yeah this one's
just dumb Wow oh god just the geyser of
blood from his crotch oh that's for his
crotch baby Jesus
so okay you got one to do you wanna do
one here I'll try I'll try elephant but
yeah you doing real good do it on not
you can't do it on the big guy you can't
do it on the boss saw it suck
I expected oh it's fine what's this I
got one of these okay
up down quick what you know they took
one of the defense sucks cuz I squeeze
that controller too hard because I was
mad once it was like ten years ago and
now that d-pad is always broken I really
wish I didn't say the last statement I
just said what just sounds bad just how
it's really really bad all right we're
gonna get this guy who walk into the
spine this won't hurt
oh stop really share an elf bar what
yeah I didn't realize yeah that's why
you need to be better than the other
guys so you don't get to be the one
who's upset when uh so you get to be the
one who's pissed off
Xavier what's your opinion on
PlayStation state of play 2019 what
happened what showed up on that like two
weeks ago because there were a ton of
games announced like two three days ago
I didn't hide please all right so what
you do is you guys one when you jump and
then you do a super jump like that or
one yeah this isn't working and then
jump oh no no no that's the thing now
it's not safe so we various we're gonna
jump off a cliff
I like the don't joke I like something
about this is that we have to get off
the island before it explodes but then
you can also come back to this same
arena like way later in the game and
it's like still flying that's great
that's good alright now we can get
across this big-ass gap what are the
times that Peter Parker was a bigger
prick than McGill O'Hara you're from
that time he ripped off some chicks face
remember that time that uh he was dating
some girl named Debra Whitman and she
found out his secret identity and then
he found out that she
he had a history of mental health issues
and then was just like oh she's just
schizophrenic I'm not spider-man and
then she got committed to a mental
institution
haha her psychiatrist is like either my
patient is in dire need of some more
help or you're spider-man but either way
we need to help we need your help to
figure out what's wrong with what's
wrong with her and then and then Peter
was like yeah brah she's just crazy like
he shows up at her doorstep later is
like you know what I of the guilt is
killing me I have to come clean Debra it
turns out you were right and he shows up
in the costume and takes off the mask
and she's like oh wow you didn't have to
do this just to make me feel better
about my dumb fantasies you know what
now that I'm seeing you here in the suit
I think you realized how stupid it is
that you'd be spider-man you don't look
anything like spider-man you're too
skinny he's like okay and then later
like like 20 years like later in real
life during [ __ ] Civil War we're
gonna get killed by a guy we can't let
him die a killer throw your hat at him
all right I will press yeah oh yeah
that's really effective because I had
that it's the coolest move you have do
it anyway so like during Civil War after
Peter Parker what the [ __ ] sirs would
bind us Oh God just throw him I will no
like this I'm trying yeah I've been
trying to grab that's why Oh sucks Oh
we collectively suck it's okay we'll try
it who else is playable with what a
helpful hint and then during Civil War
when Peters identity is revealed to the
public she publishes a book called how
Peter Parker ruined my life and it
becomes the New York Times bestseller
why we have to do the [ __ ] oh we have
to do the troll boss again are you
serious
that's [ __ ] dumb I thought we saved
LA I did oh can I no exit game can I
load my save after that sheet give it a
shot what are your thoughts on poison
the Peter venom hybrid that resurrected
Gwen Stacy that was a weird one if story
I guess I don't know I thought the the
vent
design and that was kind of neat savory
did you like Mountain Dew Baja blast no
okay
load game guts from berserk and Mortal
Kombat 11 see I don't know leave your
read comments the ones on live yeah haha
get [ __ ] bodied that's so funny dude
does he even try to read that sucks no
David's in the chat being a [ __ ] ass
he's like no David you get get the [ __ ]
out of you're fired
have you thought about reviewing Arkham
origins maybe
maíam k head can is that everything is a
drunk hallucination from Liu Kang after
bull ride shall forcefully poor dear
beer down his throat man like that Vince
look I did it I cheated so that we don't
have to do the boss I'm a hero
your you are here i side loaded the save
so that we can skip [ __ ] let's do it
let's go just keep doing are 1x and then
just yeah booster cross no they'll never
be able to stop but they can't will be
too powerful
alright I've got a savior will play
Mortal Kombat 13 with me when it comes
out nah I give it to Mortal Kombat 25
[Applause]
all right follow me I've got a plan
alright just come with me are you coming
I'm fasting you alright we're gonna lure
him over here and then just knock him
off this this is a great plan come on
gang come over here and accept your doom
or oh [ __ ]
or you could just do a fatality on one
of them that's true
I do it from [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I got I got a
scroll over the thing so you can look at
the fatality list okay okay ready go to
the alright I got slain one of these
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] gasps big penis just
hit him with the thing hey there you go
do more of those all right left up right
right quick swing yeah let's see what
that better what does it do it's the
first one
oh [ __ ] I think I know what this one is
also rabbit up oh yeah or no it's the
one from Monty Python
his friendship and mk2 was pulling a
rabbit out of his hat because they were
like this game is too violent you should
put in moves that you could befriend
your opponent then they did and it was
stupid I did it I saved the day I threw
him off the [ __ ] light we all have to
deal them down yeah all right I guess
I'll just hang back here I'll go and you
stay there and go to the rest of the
series good this cutscene looks awesome
look at that water texture tasty we had
our n Mandal romance caviar that one
series that never dies even when it
looks like it's about to die for the
third time in a row
er what is this they became super run
away run away you finally did it
would you like spawn to be DLC in MK 11
yeah I would everyone wanted spawn you
know wan to be in MK 2x
yeah they want him to be an MK X as a
guest character and then noob was like
boon was like on Twitter like making
like little hints at it and little jokes
about it and then he in spawn wasn't and
then injustice 2 rolls around he's like
hey I wonder what characters will add
this time and they upload a pole up it's
like what characters do you want to see
in one of his [ __ ] spawn right he
keeps putting all these hints and it
still wasn't him
so MK 11 rolls around and they're like
can we find the get spawn even todd
mcfarlane himself is like hey if I mean
I'm just waiting for them to like you
know return my calls if they want him
they can they can I'm like well either
of you just [ __ ] commit anyway the
cutscenes in this look thank you great
look at how sweet this is there's the
cool ass CG cutscene in the intro just
and then there's like the in-game
cutscenes like this that aren't as good
and faces like look at Raiden's face
look at Sonya Sonya looks a little bit
more expressive during Mass by far the
worst face in the game because look at
his eyes they're just so
I want moon night says someone it's true
oh you mean I just clicked on the screen
and immediately heard two nerds yelling
into them I'm so sorry
oh sorry who else do you like besides
Scorpion Savior what about Josh
I like robot smoke that's why I played
as him a whole bunch earlier distress
I mean favorite character to play in
Mortal Kombat has been Molina so far
just playing Mortal Kombat today with me
no no general like his I played one
combat 10d is decent bit and like Mortal
Kombat 3 an okay amount there are caves
but well yeah that's why I went to that
same one I think I actually filmed a
little bit of it and put in the video
you took pictures we put a video yeah I
could live stream off my phone the traps
an easy climb xavier you've done the
voices of socially inept spider-man and
drunk Scarlet Spider but do you think
you'd do roid rage cane it sounds like a
lot of fun do you want to give it a shot
no I feel like I can't just like turn it
on like a switch I gotta wait till I've
come up with something worthy no there's
a box of tacos should I buy yeah if you
want
they'll just hear the crinkling of like
Dell talked about it's a Crump shot all
over that Del Taco
alright I guess I'll commentate over
them get me the burritos with the green
chili and get the burritos
so uh looks like it's just you and me
chat how you doing what's up yeah
Godzilla Mendoza would you collaborate
with a fan I've done that a couple of
times actually if you go to that
playlist on my channel videos I mean I
mean it's videos where I'm referenced or
maybe was a livestream where I was being
particularly active in the chat it's so
like kind of like I was there
or sometimes fan videos that I just show
up in because it's like sometimes people
want to do like like sometimes people
ask me if I want to just show up and
stuff and I do thoughts on your channel
um I'd like to think it's pretty good oh
why am i getting re five fives from this
game because it's a super action heavy
two-player co-op game in a series that
is not really associated with that
xavier do you want Ashe to be dlc for MK
11 only if Bruce Campbell did the voice
ultimate are amazing amazing new BIR
sub-zero noob because I can switch out
his voice with CJ from Sub Zero and it
makes me giggle the finale arc fan true
or the Phenom V our trailer is
unintentionally hilarious is that a
thing there's a there's another fern
Afghan are you serious I thought that
series was dead god damn are you
secretly bald no I'm not I used to be
okay I did here's a funny thing I didn't
grow hair until I was like four years
old like my parents didn't know I was
gonna be they didn't know I was gonna be
a ginger because like I just didn't have
any hair on my head for like the first
couple years of my life and then it just
kind of came out of nowhere
well MK 11 be as good as mortal combat
Special Forces boy I sure hope so
there's a fine ass movie in production
well you know they confirmed that like
kinda wow that series was at the height
of its popularity and that was a pretty
long while ago I don't I feel like
that's gonna be one of those things that
ends up stuck in development hell and
then they'll make it like six years
after the fact when it the series is
just really really really [ __ ] dead
likes like like the Slender Man movie
like that game was super popular that
whole internet phenomenon was super
popular and then the movie came out it's
like oh yeah that's a thing that existed
it's just so out of date his MK vs. DC
bad no but everyone wants to pretend it
is because it doesn't have blood in it
well I mean even it has some blood but
like just because you can't like pull
someone's brain out of their ass
it's like terrible for some reason are
you secretly spider-man no but I like
dressing up as him a lot if you uh you
can follow my Instagram and I do a lot
of spider-man cosplays on there
I don't do shirtless pics on cosplay
though I've had a like for some reason
Scott keeps requesting those of me but
like no Xavier who do you think is gonna
die in endgame probably Thanos just a
theory like wait no one no ever seems to
talk about that he's probably not gonna
be around for more movies after that cuz
it's just gonna complicate things
um venom would be perfect for MK I think
a venom Mortal Kombat character that
would be cool I don't think uh I think
the rights thing would let it oh hi
what's up Wyatt
there's what's the taco box problem
literally ten boxes or ten things of
tacos you're like this big
I'm very tiny okay I don't like tacos
well you're a [ __ ] heathen opinion on
black panther honest opinion oh so
thanks for specifying I was gonna give
my dishonest opinion I was gonna say
it's the greatest movie of all time
because
because I want to impress all of my
black friends
but now it's fine I mean it's just
another Marvel movie where I've seen
like ten of them that are you know yeah
yeah very good commentary xavier
unimpressed talking to the chat while
you were gone
you really stepped up your game while I
was gone he fell on the spike oh he fell
on the spike I'm on spy get your [ __ ]
stop I'll haul you away from it so you
can't I'm coming I'm going very fast you
just say you're comin oh god x was
perfectly well we sure health bar bar
jackass why it's funny you just saw your
night you said no you
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] oh my god oh wow
now we can uppercut them on there and
yeah
see Kabam big bite Big Mike's
ah da episode why did I choose to read
the one that made no sense to me keep
putting him on the one that doesn't do
anything did these spikes are also part
of progression on the level cuz they do
special things okay all right all right
ready I'm a fatality this yeah okay get
him well I haven't distracted fatality
I'm so good yeah
dad do that one already yeah no way I
don't think I did this one oh wait maybe
I did oh I did thought there's like ten
of them and I just did the same one I've
already done rips the nads subscribe now
oh no any showcase the cool fatalities
our health is really low because you're
bad at this
shut up I wasn't even here for the
majority of the time I was just gauger
ah ah ah you suck Oh could you slow I'll
get the health items from this thing if
there is okay all right
smash me another thing right he's got
you know knock him into the really good
piece we gotta we gotta throw him into
it ready
Kabam but a dog that guy that we killed
is there again just so that the thing
looks cool he's dead broke into a bunch
of like raw meat I'll show you they're
mine I'm not yeah don't say that ben'll
edited not canon [ __ ] I don't want any
more phone number when he edited that
that bulge thing in the other video was
really good I'm very impressed I'm dying
too I think I'm so pissed that people
don't really watch the screen highlights
cuz I think it's some of the best
content on the channel
ah where's stunned collectively
fnaf battle royale meat featuring okay
from cry
well sliding or robbed blind watching
Savior's video about making costumes he
informs ever on that 2099 has a black
customer okay probably having
conversation with someone else in chat
maybe maybe he's having a conversation
doom guy in MK 11 I can see fitting that
would actually slow down cool that'd be
great because he already does fatality
no reason for not to be there you just
give them lots of gun based movies a BAM
into the spikes hey why are you fighting
them oh god no oh god just calm you're
supposed to not be on the spikes you put
them on the spike you dope
oh my mistake ow [ __ ] oh god ant are you
doing that on purpose
ah don't worry otherwise the wound with
my fireballs
flaming testicles no huh that's not what
that means here wait I'm gonna run in
and run out [ __ ] like that I just don't
want to dog ah jeez fine Birds clients
okay everyone's okay just just do the
hoppity house Go Go and then they throw
this poor month we've never hurt anybody
in his life he's promotes peace all the
time xaviar who's your smash bros picks
you don't place uh scorpion scorpion
it's a good one
I like to watch this stream I like I'm
glad stream highlights are really good
they're doing I I just actually he sent
me one today that you finished editing
and I think it's similar like the back
his best work I want to I want to show
it to you after the street oh really
it's [ __ ] awesome yeah okay we'll
just go up here and skip the fight with
that guy don't get on fire ah you suck
what was I supposed to do teleport out
with your stupid teleporting hand what's
worst Batman vs Superman Fox red
squadron Suicide Squad Suicide Squad
because at least like I mean Batman V
Superman has like story problems but
it's not coming no wait stop
Oh before disasters beckon oh god
there's so many sound clips like I was
actually talking with him the other day
there's so many sound clips for me and
you from all across all these streams
they we don't have to fight every guy
was even I want to what the [ __ ] no what
can i [ __ ] me it's progress every
mission you're a gamer [ __ ] did you hate
women what I'm calling the military
please oh god all I was trying to throw
the guy in the spikes and then you're
too slow Xavier what are you doing
you're too slow too slower you're - no
you throw them in spikes yeah wow it's
very vengeance [ __ ] you're so slow
Yannick spins what are you back there
dude you're a peep [ __ ] you piss Kop
Xavier why did you discontinue the bad
comic art series I tried to find out but
I couldn't well okay um after making a
comic I realized how hard it is and it's
kind of shitty to make fun of anybody
who's a professional comic artist cuz
goddamn
are they trying their heart out and it's
not as easy as it looks and like big
props to anybody who can do that job
except Greg lamb because he's like a
[ __ ] tracer and a thief
great I don't know how that guy's keeps
getting work there's like tons of
evidence of him tracing other people's
atomic art or better yet if he doesn't
know how to do a good like facial
expression he'll trace promotional
photos of actors so suddenly you'll be
like why is this character Kurt Russell
or better that's funny he'll just trace
faces from porn because you need he
needs a picture of and no one will ever
find that okay I need a picture of some
of a woman looking surprised
ha ha type type type [ __ ]
small killed he gets two for one right
there you can watch his sexy time and
get thing to an image straight right
there but anyway yeah so also another
thing is we ran out of bad comic art cuz
people just stopped donating they're not
doing sending any good suggestions for
it they just sent like the same ten
images over and over again ah
Barry you're my favorite person who
watches you to join Kage can do fate al
al Oh Johnny Cage he's just over here
just hanging out
I got him guys no leave it VARs leave it
now we can go to this secret area [ __ ]
what do you think a spectacular
spider-man it kicks ass we could go over
here and um coming back yeah faster than
you know I'm the fastest
we gotta keep them from hitting Johnny
while he opens the gate now that's
Johnny okay I'm gonna do a fatality now
again are you ready I mean I'm gonna do
cooling are you ready
it's gonna be so cool oh I like this one
actually
oh this one's mean just breaks all his
limbs [ __ ] cool what a nice guy you
wanna do one here if you were to play
smash ultimate which character would you
play dual fan hat EJ left right right
left launch
that's triangle that's what I'd press it
didn't happen oh it's fine we'll try
again in a moment well okay if it's one
of these things you can't do sorry you
got it back just do another one just
just pick a different Campbell you nerd
up down
are you serious oh just your [ __ ]
defense sucks I'm sorry they can you use
the joystick for it
[ __ ] that up even alright yeah you can
do it good try it well oh they did a
combo move wish we could do those like
the fan but we have to enlarge Oh what
what there you go alright right right up
up quick oh you can't do it with the
joystick did you oh oh not this one all
this ones mean oh my god
really oh no it's from MKX all right
least it's in go yeah yeah it's cool
that's great it's premium oh that's cool
while you were at the arcade did you
play my favorite Street Fighter game
which one
Street Fighter third strike I think that
one was broken and we had to get the guy
to come no way it's broken no no like
there's something like a coin was jammed
in the machine and the guy had to go fix
it he's just taking so long that we
didn't get around to it it's the best
machine there lol XD is it actually I
love that that is probably one of my
all-time favorite games
oh god oh jesus oh my just spin move
just keep doing the flippety-flip s'
alright now just let's go punch John
what the [ __ ] he's using his telekinetic
powers just throw them off the ledge so
that they can't do nothing probably look
back at the chat again at some time oh
my god - before they start screaming and
crying read read and he hopes for venom
- I hope carnage is in it and I hope
they fix his wig alright it's kind of
stupid and trashy but like in like a fun
way like don't go into it expecting Dark
Knight or or Winter Soldier go into it
expecting like would you slap Josh to
get spectacular spider-man back yeah if
it was really all that took like to get
the next like I don't know how many like
26 episodes of that show that we didn't
get and all I had to do is just slap
Josh I would do it I'll do all right now
hey I made you flinch
hahaha [ __ ] you hit me no Josh you made
it cancelled even more gasps it's not
canceled you'll never get it back it's
your fault you son of a [ __ ] we almost
had it we had it you ruined it
you suck ah Ben says he loves me thanks
Ben I love him too you're a swell fella
you're a fell swallow I fell swallow
my name is okay not all of it can be
gold not all of it can be in Kegel
follow me into this em into this empty
hallway Shaolin monks is pretty close
that no it's not a prequel it's it's
just a retelling of Mortal Kombat tune
but specifically only from the
perspective of Kung Lao and Duquesne
follow me in this hallway doctor I'm
talking Tommy you sucked into certain
sound clips of you saying that like Ben
can just make like a hole like you stop
giving them ideas but God hey he's got
to have fun with this a little I let him
have fun on his own time I'm not gonna
flush it all right okay you've acquired
a health upgrade yeah thank you
right yeah Raiden [ __ ] off riding is the
other guy the ninja with the super sword
I played this the other day with Jackson
and we got lost for like two hours
because we couldn't [ __ ] figure out
the you just had to go over here it's so
stupid
there's no indicator at all that that's
where you gotta go all right so you cut
the lines yeah like that and then weed
and then and then we do a cool cutscene
and we'll be like will fend off the
Baraka means how much longer do you
think the streams gonna go for I don't
know until I get born we never really
know
I need to know about the Mortal Kombat
film and told me now all right it's it's
a movie that exists did you see Liu Kang
just kind of wipe his nose you just like
alright to adjust my nose that live
action Dora the explora movie trailers
look so [ __ ] bad Larry it's like the
it's like that [ __ ] parody trailer
someone did where they're like let's
make it like a lot like a Hollywood
action movie where Dora gets tied up by
terrorists and then that's actually what
the real one is like oh remember how
interactive and like light-hearted and
low stakes the show was you know it's
just like it was so fun and cutesy and
had like no bearing on reality and now
now we got this [ __ ] this live-action
version where she gets kidnapped by
South American terrorists and trapped in
a box with other children that the CA
goes like this [ __ ] [ __ ] ass high
school boys like Dora you're [ __ ]
wacky what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
stop being so weird that night Jordan
[ __ ] Diego is weirder the Dora
why does it boots where food frustrating
please oh my god implying that door is
actually good did you just use implying
I'm just like I didn't imply it the show
was good I just said that it was
something else it's very different don't
talk [ __ ] on Dorothy flora dude that
[ __ ] to do all headed in pink
Xavier give me something tedious to do
while editing being tortured is my king
okay Ben um just any time we bring up a
movie put in a clip of them what No yeah
don't actually are you I guess you could
but that's a lot of [ __ ] work why
would you do that to yourself make it
just as hard as possible why doesn't
wear boots wear boots
I know characters you want as DLC an MK
11 I wanted robot smoke but we already
got him so I guess we probably won't so
if I'm if we're picking like stupid
characters that are silly Shinji from
even go
sure why not I wanna I wanna shrunk down
Godzilla look at that oh look at this
guy he's having such a hard time I - I'm
having a hard time all right hang on
hang on oh god you gotta help me man I
gotta walk over this thingy okay already
you guys ready to see guys super power
button no I can do it super good look I
can get it all the way to the thing I
know I just wanted to I just want Brad
that's impressive
I can I have such fast twist twitch
reflex muscles and my wrists because I
used to play the drums that I can tap
super fast yeah do because drums
transfer to single finger pressing well
no it's cuz I was using my wrist use
your wrist for that dude oh yeah [ __ ]
arm dude well
watch my arm already oh my god no I have
an aneurysm and that's how I do my
girlfriend's are lucky lady I like rich
and Josh vs. Xavier I was Chad of Stassi
and Chad I stole that joke from myself
in the exact same context because I
recorded some gameplay of this for the
for the retrospective with Jackson I set
the same [ __ ] joke all right that
guy's dead let's go would you want
Josh's DLC um Taylor let's see I don't I
use my toe or what button mashing your
fingering if you want Josh's Oh God oh
wait I don't light it where what would
you want Josh's DLC am Kayla I already
said that Xavier I'm sorry I don't know
I don't pay attention to things you know
just in general you want try it try the
thing do the mashing right here we wanna
see you doing it all right watch my
dream I'm gonna be proud of you use your
middle finger let's see
I'll see what are you alright holy [ __ ]
he's like vibrating his hand like he's
the [ __ ] flash oh man if you do that
fast enough you can phase it through the
control
he'll be cool good job yeah fast-track
'test moving my wrist room yes brothers
super mash brothers really good when I
left yeah fast Ben Photoshop a cover for
super mash Brothers Ball brawl
super mash brothers ball we're fine [ __ ]
it yeah that cuz you know I'm on fire I
can't do it as fast as he did actually
you're not holding it correctly you're
not using the proper form Brooke your
form is trash engage your core more my
form is trash I'm gonna use mine I'm
just kidding something's coming out oh
Jesus Christ
it was David I know don't worry he's one
of the only three people on the planet
who knows what [ __ ] osoo is mankind I
ever tell you that PewDiePie play dosoo
and then like an entire okay that
validates it is something good no I
didn't say that I just said people knew
about it what the [ __ ] what the words in
my mouth whoa whoa jerkbait whoa [ __ ]
beat whoo ha ha whoa I'm of legal age of
legal near a baby ah I'm not fart we
were supposed to like put out the fire I
think and then me [ __ ] it up oh well
hang on
good follow me oh we got I've ran into
doctor ah this is a bad day I'm having a
rough day here guys I love u s-- Xavier
was a good one I laughs I don't think
everyone's I heard triple Xavier before
not one was from Anna what what's she
saying she she calls she uh she has a
special folder on her phone called
Xavier but with three X's and I want you
to guess what's in there
nothing yeah
anyway hold on no no that's not the way
that's not over here this is doing yeah
do you know the way of the devil
oh [ __ ] that joke did teleport into the
higher yeah there you go against it I
saved you I got it guys do it doesn't
Super Smash Bros sound more like gay
porn yeah
Xavier do you like Deadpool if Deadpool
is in MK 11 for DLC he wouldn't be but I
would like that I'll be neat I'll be
kind of weird
Xavier you're my favorite youtuber oh
thank you your music embarrassing what's
your favorite Mortal Kombat game on this
one actually what really yeah I love
this one this one's fun but I disagree
it gets good
it gets better I mean it's I don't know
just core gameplay wise maybe it's just
because I like the fact that you can do
so much with the other kind of games
with being competitive
I like competitively okay if you want if
you want me to pick one of the fighting
game ones then like a real ones
I either deception or 11
is it 2011 110 is it bad just that it
uses all of it does it justice and I
know this is stupid but tens aesthetic
kind of sucks because everything's so
dark and grimy
I like Mortal Kombat when it's colorful
when you get to see a colorful bloody
violent game it's always like you know
well I have the option suggestion before
you ever heard of mad world I'll pull up
a picture for you real I've heard of it
real good do you know delay of the
Tungus god damn that's 21 funny means at
the same time get a D you're you're
fired from the stream o niala holy ohina
this is what mad world looked like all
around like the entire game looks like
that cut all where it's all just like
like comic books yes me but on top of
that whenever you did a kill or anything
whenever is anything like that happened
it was blood remember so it would flash
like this it acts like ultraviolent just
like there it is there's our big boy
that guy looks me he's got like
cel-shading I've never actually played
it was on the wii and there was a lot of
motion controls you feel like you were
using chainsaw bantam zero wing the next
Mortal Kombat video will be on the
movies and shows and also other silly
stuff like the live tour and the action
figures and the comics like I want to
just talk about how like big of a
phenomenon it became because there were
so many silly things that were tied into
it I mean there's even a TV show I
showed Josh my DVD of it earlier there's
a there's a spin-off TV TV show about
kung Laos ancestor the original Kung Lao
who I guess gets killed by Goro to
Outworld know at least one oh my god I'm
not reading that Raiden sounds like a
virgin honey how do you sound like a
virgin you're doing it right now
ah it fired no wait that's that's the
anti-progress way we go this
anti-progress you know how burn you know
we're all there wasn't even fire what oh
stop I you got it my oh no it was shot
off this way down here huh I'm coming
I'm fast Chozen 1 I'm coming Chozen 1
wow what the spikes it can even tell
that whole wall of spikes for some
reason there's also this [ __ ] trap
over here and you know what Josh I know
how you feel about those I love them
they're sweet cut to that other clip
what's this one I want to grab them I
just want to grab a bit No oh yeah well
[ __ ] you but oh god you suck oh no no
they're uh
I pressed all the buttons
right oh [ __ ] his hands are on four oh
wow
Brad that's cool I definitely I mean
they can't all be as elaborate it's like
cutting his dick off with a hat you do
that whenever you don't know how to
whenever you don't have anything else to
say funny good noise this is it funny
that was very funny what are your
thoughts an iron fist it was a show that
was that didn't need to get made and I
wish it hadn't it's like it's it's
almost as bad as Luke Cage but not quite
it's just because Luke Cage is like
egregiously terrible well as iron fist
is just like kind of like yeah like it's
boring and then Daredevil and Jessica
Jones are awesome and then defenders
it's like Regis Lee terrible Luke Cage
is so [ __ ] boring and unwatchable
I've talked about it before I bet
they'll talk about an hour all right
then put clips all right so here's
here's a rundown in the first episode of
Luke Cage alright so Luke Cage is
working at his job I had a barber shop
he has some some talks with with his
boss about about how cool it is that he
has superpowers and then he leaves to go
to his other job he works two jobs
because he needs to pay his rent you
know it's hard to it's hard to pay right
so he walks through New York has a
couple conversations with people on the
way then I he he gets to his other job
as a dishwasher but but though the
waiter isn't on staff that night at the
restaurant so they put him in an
ill-fitting waiter uniform and have him
sir or no bartender that bartenders
alright not waiter so he tends the bar
while also doing the dishes
but then he needs a pretty lady and then
takes her back to his apartment and you
know they do stuff and that is the first
episode of my TV show about a man with
bulletproof skin who can lift a car over
his head episode I think episode 3 is
literally just four different
conversations all in the same location
and all they do is just walk into a
different rooms like the third episode
tell him and pops have a conversation
out front then they walk inside and then
a character shows up then they have a
conversation with him and then he leaves
and then they go into the back room and
then have a conversation with another
character and then walk back out into
the front and then a drive-by happens
and the shoots everyone in the room and
that's the whole episode
it's [ __ ] abysmal the pacing is so
goddamn bad like nothing happened you
have a show about a man with bulletproof
skin and he needs to be convinced for
like 13 episodes of season by other
characters to actually use that for
something practice why don't you guys
upgrade the Shaolin punks oh yeah we can
oh we can yeah what oh yeah
hell I mean I guess I'm out of upgrade
juice already that was useful now I can
do two fireballs that'll miss everything
you can upgrade as well if you thought I
you know what I can't do fatalities on
these guys because they don't have legs
fish on reason I'm not upgrading my
shelling punk who's an upgrade let's run
up in speed running this whole time
actually oh [ __ ] this was a speed run
but it was secret mods I'm doing patrol
Doom Patrol now that daredevil is gone
is the best comic book related TV show
out there it's [ __ ] awesome everyone
should watch dooms what do you think
about that new
it takes place on the moon where it
takes place as where the main character
takes the entire situation really
seriously it looks like any other
generic garbage Space Station movie Doom
is that it's fun and stupid and overly
violent and like like the main character
is supposed to be just like this
emotionless kind of psycho and make
aliens but to have the monsters not be
as interesting all right I'm going first
Xavier did you like Shazam if you've
seen it I haven't seen it you should
have just broke my desk just now l'm out
winter what the [ __ ] listen I told you
not to masturbate oh god no that's open
habit but then katana showed up and it
got a lot harder to do that oh I'm sorry
to not masturbate no it's good oh my
guess jaha my swords out would you like
me to grab you yeah give me a soda well
I run around and talk to the chat I'm
gonna enjoy myself all over my desk and
keep God what would you do to get
spectacular back what's your limit um
nothing that involves killing anyone
nothing that involves poop but like
other than ads kind of free game I guess
well nothing now involves significant
jail time or other penalties I also
don't have very much money so I wouldn't
really like want to spend a lot
basically I mean if if it's gonna be a
weird sex thing like I can understand
that and I'll I'll come to terms with
that because I love spectacular so if I
need to take it up the butt to make
spectacular comeback I I guess I can
I'll try Xavier have you seen Steven
universe yet I have not yet well I'm
gonna go to bed guys good stream thanks
for showing up Jay ray 3:58 you're our
good
good fella thank you I've read the first
arc of Hellboy I thought was pretty good
Savior what's your thoughts on heaven
fill ARCA just go watch that stream that
was on his channel where him and I
played MK vert
Marvel vs. Capcom and I just made fun of
him the whole time that's my opinion of
him
human smoker Robo smoke or and why Robo
smoke specifically the one that looks
more like the other robot ninjas because
I don't like his weird floaty smoke
limbs design it's dumb and then human
smoke is just like I mean he's cool but
he's still he just looks a little less
impressive than the other ninjas just
cuz he's just like gray is kind of a
boring color Iron Fist vs. Moon Knight
who would win
I feel like Iron Fist would win because
his martial arts is superior but Moon
Knight is just so [ __ ] crazy that he
might like freaked him out so bad that
he would just like be at a disadvantage
like one time Moon Knight tried to fight
taskmaster and he was just too lazy to
actually like fight him fight him so he
just crashed a [ __ ] plane into him
don't you hate it when people dismiss
good DC TV shows because of the bad DC
movies I feel like people dismiss DC TV
shows because of the bad DC TV shows
like have you seen arrow what's your
favorite boss in this one my favorite is
Ermac I think the boss with reptile or
scorpion no scorpion the scorpion boss
in this game is [ __ ] oh it's so cool
good still running I didn't have to miss
the stream yeah you don't have to miss
it toast man VR ps4 2025 confirmed what
are your thoughts on iron fist as a
superhero he's alright I don't mind the
fact that he's a white guy but some
people don't like that hi Josh how are
you what did you hit I'm choking on a
taco oh god that's is that a euphemism
what's this the [ __ ] is this
chicharrones this is pork rinds which is
another word for chicharrones kinda I
mean I guess it's food where'd you get
this swallow look I'm trying my best
here downstairs from the taco box you
guys want some chocolate box let me get
you some taco box Dom I can't share
roast I would guys selfish as [ __ ]
I played the Metro fames I think he
means games I have not was your least
favorite Godzilla monster um I'm trying
to remember the names of all of them
it's been so long since I've seen any of
those program for really fun I just
watch a Jackie Chan movie he doesn't go
really but oh my Willemijn scrubs man my
sin pies didn't notice my two comments
from like 30 minutes to an hour ago the
health bar disappears if you don't do
anything okay so you can take pictures
on your flip phone of this one Savior I
assume you watch Ben 10 so who's your
favorite alien uh Heatblast he's neat he
had a cool voice because he was Steve
Steve Blum dude like that's a bro I is
really cool he's he's like he's like a
bat and a spider and a scorpion salkinds
a gross looking he's also kind of like a
dragon that's a throw I like just a [ __ ]
zillion different conflicting design
elements and he looks awesome he's scary
sounds scary did you want another Mortal
Kombat movie you know honestly I feel
like Mortal Kombat's kind of prime real
estate for a movie adaptation cuz like
it was done right wacky bar because
here's the thing is that the characters
are really interesting and fun and wacky
and there's a lot you can do with them
and they seem to have a different arc
every game that you could use but also
like the stories themselves are really
basic and there's just like you don't
really got to do a whole lot like just
like it's not like God of War where you
have to adapt like 200 different things
cuz he fights how many people in those
games right right or he goes to so many
different locations or he does so many
different things like you don't have to
cut down the amount of events it's you
kind of have to build up upon what's
already there
cuz it's so basic like I feel like
Mortal Kombat you could make a really
kick-ass movie out of and it's kind of
baffling why no one's done it yet I mean
like I thought legacy was really good
there's this like live-action like like
web series that was produced officially
um and it was like a tie-in for the
games but it only ran for like ten Efes
it only ran for like 20 episodes was it
so cheesy like it's it's really hard to
hit that point right like Mortal Kombat
has a very specific tone to because it
takes itself very seriously but also not
seriously at all you would need a
specific like a very specific type of
director oh yeah you need someone who
could do you wanna get going
I have pork rinds in my right hand and a
controller in his land my other phone in
my left who's playing the game we're
both playing the game what if you could
create a Deadpool game what would it be
like uh I think gameplay wise the the
first one that they did was pretty solid
earth core shooter
that weird that I find first person
shooters immensely boring it's because
you played of Trillian to them and you
were born during an era where they were
completely saturated I was oh yeah but
about your saturation being bored of
them it's known as the era that you were
born completely very yeah because like
when when like I started like really
getting into video games was at the
height of like the ps3 and like every
[ __ ] game in that era was a third was
a first-person shooter ever since the
90s though like even then because their
way yeah cuz I know quake clones yeah
there's a time I wasn't like there was
an actual market for life and then see
yes like anything do you ever strike
related get into like halo around like
2000 and ever played halo modern warfare
then there was like crazy wacky stuff
like bullet storm or they try to change
the genre but by being [ __ ] crazy
then there were third-person shooters
which played very similarly everything
yeah then there is like you're the only
alternative the first-person shooters is
here's another Gears of War clone well
waste I cover there were a decent bit of
those my like how that guy runs over I
feel like uncharted 4 was a good
third-person shooter but that's because
it had so many other gameplay types in
it that made it not boring for Uncharted
oh the tertiary yeah I mean like the
climbing the puzzles you know like just
little extra things to break up the
monotony of killing you know just dudes
it's because there's actually one of the
first times where like a well-written
story was our a cohesive story played
such an integral part I know I can't say
that you know middle
[ __ ] come out a while but we got
throw these guys on these spikes over
here to pass a matter of fact people
would argue that miyazaki hayao
miyazaki's Miyazaki is the guy who made
Mario the reason Mario even exists
because he was language I liked all the
stories that my parents told me when I
was little
why don't we have those in video games
and then he put them in video games so
that's why there's a plumber being
chased around by a monkey but mario has
such a basic nothing right but he was
one of the same for every game one of
the first people who actually made it
the first person to try to give a
narrative yeah am I like a pretentious
douchebag [ __ ] if I go I want the
Mario games to have another narrative
like actually try to do something else
you know I'm on this spike okay I'm
really tired of Bowser kidnaps the
princess go saver well that's the thing
it ends the game with why did you try to
save her this has been the same thing
several times and then like I don't know
there's there's a big conversation about
it at the end of the game you gotta
fight we got fun more guys to fight I
guess I'm coming down here yeah okay
there it is alright stop kicking them
and throw them onto this spike why right
Wow that's how we get the door open they
perform a blood sacrifice [ __ ] [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] I'll uppercut him it's fine
protective god damn no look it's not as
easy as you thought it was I'm gonna get
ya there we go it's super easy you're
just a coward
you just suck your [ __ ] you fool coward
alright that's a good one thanks person
who's doing that you're great you're
sweet I love you my computer would uh
would like load I can ban that person
[Music]
this games cool do i watch Rick and
Morty yeah yeah I liked it I mean I
didn't stop liking it
I just um watched any of those illusions
at all or anything someone said I missed
a collectible doodle I can't walk up
there I'm trying really hard
we'll get the collectibles hang on right
there it's up there you're gonna just
smash the window there you go
now get it this is working out really
well for us how do we get that maybe
like this but uh trying to record a
person who's spamming something bad in
the chat while also trying to do this
[ __ ]
got it thanks then you put him in
timeout do you only like them k one
through three characters no I like I
actually really liked the characters
from MKX I think that they were pretty
neat and everyone's just I think
everyone just hates change
they hate new ideas they like seeing the
same thing they've seen a billion times
already so let's introduce a whole bunch
of new characters that have like new
gimmicks and new powers it's like no
it's not the ones that I grew up with
it's bad how the thing over here oh yeah
I see ah dude yeah Ben's a [ __ ]
baller did Ben delete all those messages
as a [ __ ] baller he's kicking buddy
all right thanks Ben you're being a good
mod oh we got a hold on bxq see if you
like boom you're bad you're bad get out
of here [ __ ] you step on these buttons I
don't know what that did oh it it
activated a secret passage let's go down
here what's done
follow me into the secret path to come
on secret passage oh wait there we go
what's down here I actually don't know
ah we both took a collective sip of our
drug over a drink is okay what's down
here we had purple drink this is an
optional area I don't know what this is
got haters from 4chan his 4chan even
know it that's really funny actually if
that's actually happening I really doubt
it was 4chan know I exist and or care
Xavier maybe moved it remove the chat
overlay on OBS maybe okay I guess I
should do that then goodbye alright yeah
it looks like there's more people coming
in well that sucks
that's pretty funny I'm impressed no
it's it's impressive that you've gotten
enough of a fanbase that like some
people one of the [ __ ] are actually
trying to raid you
is that how I mean that's how you know
you're you did it Wow I'm famous now ma
look people are trying super hard to be
funny and it's not working I know man
just make like six five more people more
mods I'm trying so hard to walk over to
this experience points item and you keep
like fighting dude I'm sorry struggle
against the tide
yeah how many people are moms right now
I guess then and then get someone else
because I had I know Mason and William
and Anna or like I don't know like I
guess not everyone's in the screen he
says get an auto band thing oh yeah I
got you don't worry I'm gonna I'm gonna
go over here and try to figure that out
while you do that
I wish I knew how to do
I clip through the back it disappeared
I put automatically blocks BAM
automatically spent like blocks
backwards
moderator is it bots that are just
standing the thing or is it I mean it
can be a lot of people just use boxing
noise most the time you organized like
extreme
Hey pardon my interruption is a modern
achat what yeah that channel you can't
get to anymore I'm gonna go god damn
look at how many things Ben's had to do
I don't block words there we go I can
put I can I can block that
what does it matter
like like the lowercase or uppercase in
my take it well actually okay save
all right let's see if that changed
anything because I block the word that
are you just jumping over here I am I
was protecting you I protected us how
many counts do this guy happen is it one
guys like it's a cup of tea
how does he switch an out so fast unless
is his password for each email is like
just different three computers over
wants to put that much work in like a
lot of people do that's why people for
what what reaction did you want to get
out of that do you want me like scream
and cry your knowledge meant spam filter
that's on so far as I know let me go
back and oh it's raining super hard
outside hold potentially inappropriate
comments for review in beta it says it's
in beta
it's [ __ ] BAM okay I also put certain
words blocked in there so
all right how about that
is that changing anything here's the
situation still terrible
my least favorite Godzilla monsters
north they don't want six to work out so
Meireles to me that wasn't screaming
yeah you know what AR you can be another
model we can't click on it there we go
caching there you go there you go
then just time people out
not even [ __ ] banner [ __ ] get him
the juice [ __ ] get him out of here oh
yeah all right let's go it's easier to
handle this kind of [ __ ] which it's true
he's right you guys twitch Auto online
says his least favorite Godzilla monster
is manila manila stupid woman okay come
on oh it's his name so bypasses the
filter what it's all it's all those
accounts are just named that word so it
bypasses the filter he's not even really
typing the word it's just the name
I'll make Henderson
oh god it's so hard to play this while
also dealing with stupid people
Oh God
I mean yeah it was an eventualities at
something like this with yeah I'm just
impressed to happen it just rate alright
so what happens is you use the new
corpses as a thing to get out see what
I'm fine that guy gassy Savior you're a
P P but have five bucks anyways thanks
patty Mac what a nice man you know so
slow mode
oh yeah should I save your why doesn't
anyone asked Josh questions they have
from time to time but sometimes we just
get caught up doing Oh like this yeah
and then people can't talk unless they
wait 60 seconds so they can't spam chat
okay
yeah alright just click done at the
bottom alright let's see if that chain
that goes for everyone but whatever
so you'll see him but you won't be able
to spin you shouldn't be able to spam
unless he has a ton of accounts alright
which he does if anyone could try to add
the discord link go ahead and do that
Josh you Josh from drinking Josh yep
Josh how are you I'm good it's like our
own name Josh like that
what it's just something related that's
true have you have you dealt with a lot
of that in your life house we were kind
of at the high you were you were born at
the height of that show is popular here
I was born at the right time yeah oh
look that window for no reason I'm just
really mad okay
I hate windows I mean it's not the best
operating system but I don't think it's
the word do you do I think the Avengers
project is still happening I mean I
guess maybe been saying to shut down the
stream soon all right you know how about
we get to the boss which is like right
at the top of this tower and then wool
after that well we could call it quits
oh it sucks that they're bots oh hey we
get a mole tality it's a it's a fatality
that you can do to multiple people at
once oh geez which sounds cool and
practice there sounds cool in on paper
but in practice is not very interesting
we need to get two bars full fatalities
yeah I do it by filling up the fatality
comes with the blood of your enemies I
guess
just keep smashing them until it works
I'm close I'm close I can do the aah oh
boy oh God why I want it it's look at
how close it is we died look how close
it was didn't fill up the bar all the
way you were floating Oh
what will the catapults reveal Josh mime
dig would you spend all night right now
shut up oh gee I was trying I know I'm
keep saying it all can't be gold but try
harder than that
look man see if you're you listen to
Tupac you listen to [ __ ] you listen
vegan both he side are west side which
one I don't I listen more to like like
Ice Cube and I really like far side I
set our sights on glass
yes lot of looting man Busta Rhymes this
experiment roared Busta Rhymes filled
Michael Myers been pretty clip what okay
okay you got the mult allottee thing
just do it so we can pass this error all
right I will I will just fatalities ass
all right there I do oh that you did it
thoughts on Nick Spencer's hunted
storyline I haven't read it
I've got me super behind on comics I've
barely been able to read them lately cuz
I've been working so hard on like videos
it's it's hard for me to sit down and
spend a couple hours reading comics
lately even though I used to do that all
the times I can read like three issues
in a day oh god oh god we both fell on
the spikes Oh
get me out of here get me out of here ah
alright oh my god alright I'll jump up
here and you can teleport there you go
alright what's a 'birthday are safe
follow me or throw the shadow placement
doesn't let me oh I think I think it's
cuz he's character model was dumb and
doesn't have legs
okay you over the ledge okay just throw
your hat at him until he gets bored and
decides to leave I got you pretty slam
go get them there I go there I go all
right there we go over here just choose
some random place literally worst
ability
I mean it's useful in combat when you're
getting like no you get knocked out of
that
Xavier do you like the first to play
Glaven movies ever I really I really
like the second one really yeah bleh -
it's really it's fun it's it's like
stupid and goofy because like that's
kind of what you could do with blades
but the second movies a lot of fun we're
giving Ben a lot of good really good get
him so much so much dude that's great
I'm being honest I'm falling asleep at
the wheel still have a discord Sonny
just curious I mean I do but like anyone
who's in my server do you like who's
also a mom now on anyone got them
because the for some reason the links
just keep like expiring on me like every
time I find one that I put in the
description of stuff it just stops they
just stopped working I was biased one
that you can use
we'll make sure I know I specifically
set it to not expire in the settings and
then it always expires after we're not
sure someone's asking my opinion on the
Iron Man 3 twist you know I think um I
think I'm fine with it honestly because
you know like I understand why they
don't want to adapt the Mandarin as he
was cuz the character just kind of
doesn't age well you know I jumped it
that was odd you see that that was cool
and then you were just like oh um just
like that okay they cancel the links
because of people fearing about raiding
the server well fair enough
oh wait which save did you save over I
don't know okay thank God default please
save over my other one where I add all
the characters unlocked follow me all
right we're gonna beat up its mess again
you know katana look at her booty look
at her PS - but yes - booty is this is
this character model not good enough for
the source filmmaker community to do
nefarious things with shut up you don't
I well I want them to have those ideas I
want to encourage their creativity if
they want to do that with the Mortal
Kombat characters then they have every
right to you know I don't mind that the
characters are being desexualized in the
eleventh game because I know I can just
Google pictures than I'm naked if I
wanted to see that he would take like
two seconds you know and it would be the
game character models - that's that's we
live in that era of Technology I got you
what's this
goddamn dude ready watch this one
[ __ ] ready for new one oh no wow
overpowered please nerve you know rest
of us [ __ ] laude Jesus you don't ever get
to play the game anymore
[ __ ] you alright fine I'll just I'll
just chill out over here and read the
chat
remember the straw poll you made I've
made several Lu Kang you're beautiful
oh yeah cuz there's oh wait because of
the movies like making Lu Kang and
katana a couple because I guess they
needed to establish a new king had a
case of enough gays it's it's just like
this weird stilted thing where katana
and Liu Kang are supposed to be a couple
but in the games at no point in any of
them except for maybe the 2011 like
really do they have any chemistry and in
that one they both get killed off so it
doesn't matter
great who's your favorite director uh
probably John Carpenter he's just done
so many movie that I like like I'm not
big on Halloween but I [ __ ] love the
thing and escape from New York and the
the fog what else oh they live I have a
poster of they live I love they live
Josh if you're in a murder Xavier how
would you yeah like this bike right here
by throwing an at me but then I do that
and then you all right so this pocketing
my thighs oh right over your face yeah
all right so she gets she's mind
controlled to be evil so you throw her
into that and it'll for some reason
break the mind-control curse if she's in
it for long enough but then but then
guess what have you guessed John no I
haven't since you have to grab two big
ball look look it's Jade oh no not like
there's that Molina model for nefarious
SS stop it do it come on someone believe
me I demand a house that's it you know
it's not even a request now it's a
command just someone figure it out
alright damn Molina is very spooky
what's your opinion on Metal Gear Solid
I think it's great I wish I could play
more of those games but they're just so
long that I don't really have funny kiss
names Senator Armstrong nice all right
we gotta fight all three of them great
let's go ah just the holster they all
have different cool moves that they all
use at the same time it's awesome really
fighting first are we killing first
which oh we got to get we got a knock
katana
we got a beat-up katana so that she'll
fall under the thing alright and then
after that we got to keep them from stop
oh no she blocks it oh hey they know how
to block gosh vegan block oh [ __ ] we
have a co-op move if you do that spinny
move and I shoot a fireball at you
little shoot them all in different
direct red II okay hang on I got knocked
down okay hang on I got you so good
right do it again oh I saw what I did it
I guess not it's not working oh okay
look so he gives her a big cuddly hug
and throws her in there we gotta stop
them from touching these panels
like a little while and for the spells
broken I got it I'll dig I'll just
[ __ ] just a camp over here no it's
fine I got the spin move I'll just
uppercut Jade anytime she gets close all
right I'll just follow you
yo stop him only you yeah man no one's
alright we did it we saved katana she is
now a Goodman except in MKX where she's
literally the [ __ ] devil and it
becomes the new ruler of hell but I'll
be here I'll be here her evil king dude
bro it'll be great man the new timeline
is so dumb Amir oh hey that's a health
item don't pick that up yet pick that up
after they've kicked our ass a lot so go
try knock them into these things cuz
it'll do like like like really big
damage
got you let me do it [ __ ] beat up these
two linen with our strong manly muscles
Oh big muscle boy oh yeah I didn't work
again maybe you just have to do a
certain amount of damage and they'll
follow I don't know I don't know the
rules of this crazy game it's not like
I've been playing this for 14 years I'm
dumb alright let's trade dance partners
you go kick Molina I'm in the team ah
look at that animation that's great Oh
on fire how old are you savior I am 20
ah oh [ __ ] she got out no oh no no she's
still on the ground
you just thought she was Molina cuz
Molina and katana they're literally the
same character except real clothes in
the face like she's a clone of Catan
I did I did thank you for the education
I met Laura
I know a lot of things I'm so impressive
and handsome I know a lot about Star
Wars spaceships the girls should date me
all right what's his name Ernest find
good job good one
very good his client is so [ __ ] sad
and lame dude Ernest Cline makes me want
to like I you know actually like usually
I feel like David's too rough on people
like you just like pick celebrities to
hate at random I'm like come on you
don't gotta be like that Ernest Cline
totally deserves that right I forgot I
had this kick look at this oh god my god
my ass bro yeah the Jade you do it while
I do this [ __ ] all right
okay you can do it I believe in you do
you know they were making a shang-chi
movie in the MCU yes it did I went on a
little bit of a rant about it on Twitter
because I think so many people are gonna
suddenly just magically pretend to be
huge fans of Chi shang-chi for what
points it's like oh I love shang-chi
he's my favorite Asian American
superheroes like all right name one
villain from him I'll get you a head you
think you're real shanked chief and his
his main villain is literally [ __ ]
named foo Manchu yeah
my favorite about using American I'm
dating an Asian and I think Xin Jie's
I'm gonna do it right I'm gonna do it
I'm doing my hip thrust just to impress
her see that Jade holy [ __ ] whoa she's
fine she's fine too it just gets right
back up oh [ __ ] Molina is all stunned so
let's just like lay in Jade so we can do
the fatality because we have to do the
fatality on Belvin you do a different
move just like do a combo like this
combo we miss all right Erica I'm gonna
do it I did it I saved the day those are
so [ __ ] awesome
I want a like I want a Mortal Kombat
movie made by those guys also did you
see that you stabbed Jade in the face
with their own with Molina spooky knife
yeah and Melina's like just gonna lay
over there and be like wow thank you Tom
is like wow you killed my clone pretty
close
thoughts on once upon a time in
Hollywood I haven't seen that I haven't
seen much about it I think I think Bruce
Lee is gonna beat up Leonardo DiCaprio
or Brad Pitt one of the two and that
sounds cool what this is a movie where
Bruce Lee well it's once upon a time in
Hollywood untick splay sin the seventies
not die hard yeah that was a little bit
overkill cuz he only needed to stab her
in the face with one side but he did
both again that's part of my theory
Mortal Kombat characters are so [ __ ]
hard to kill that you got to do stuff
that's over the top because they'll just
like heal from it like I mean why else
would they be like I'm gonna cut you
into individual molecules or I'm gonna
disintegrate you an acid or like I'm
gonna punch you so hard - all of your
limbs fly on these are really good
questions I feel like all that stuff
like I can only sleep at night knowing
that they have
do those kinds of moves Tom's chest like
all the way through and like pulls his
hand out you see his [ __ ] gaping hole
where his heart used to be and he gets
back up a little bit while laters like
wow what a dick and then he heals up in
time to do the events of MORTAL KOMBAT
died how he didn't die they had it
didn't he they had to use magic to blee
I've been just going back and forth on
the stream in the discord server making
sure everything isn't exploding all
right yeah we'll probably uh we'll
probably cut it off here now that the
cutscene is almost over
Tristan Taylor do you hate me no I don't
what from the Avengers end game theory
regarding ant-man you know exactly what
I'm talking about you talked about
earlier earlier before this dream I
think it it's not a theory it's more of
like just a dumb fan request and it's
it's on the same level to me and my mind
is like let's get shaggy for MK 11 it's
it's stupid it's fun it's fun to joke
about and make memes about but it's not
gonna actually happen at best
travesty ultra best there will be a line
of dialogue where ant-man jokes about it
was like what if I just fly up his butt
and expand and make him explode and then
someone one of the other characters will
go that's stupid
it's terrible alright we're know he's
not gonna do it Jake from fart from
farms from farms whatever he does do it
well you know you're around everybody
this portal is the end of the stream if
you jump into that portal Josh that
means the stream Elend [ __ ] well I gotta
be careful too so it's been a fun time
thanks so much everyone for donating and
hanging out and being cool except for
that one [ __ ] you know who you are or
maybe multiple ones I don't know or
unless you're just a bot in which case
good for you whoever program leader is
an [ __ ] well yeah it was fun we had a
lot of fun goofing around playing MK
games and gabbing about them and then
just making jokes and whatnot I don't
know when josh is gonna be back so if
I'm in college he's in college and it's
far away so hard to make videos yeah you
better
you finished you know what I'm giving
you a deadline what you know what finish
a video before April okay two days yeah
what the [ __ ] do it no ok finish it
before the end of April how about that
oh my god alright I'll try okay anyway
so this was fun thanks for showing up
and check out